David Boder: [In English] August 31st, 1946. Italy... the Castle Tradate between Milan and Como. The Interviewee is George Kaldore, twenty three (23) years old, born in Hungary.
David Boder: [In German] Also George, sagen Sie mir, wie alt waren Sie und wo waren Sie, wie der Krieg anfing? Sagen Sie uns nochmal Ihren Namen und alles.
George Kaldore: Mein Name ist George Kaldore, geboren in Ungarn in Stadt Szombathely bei der Östereichichen-Ungarischen Grenze, 23 Jahre alt bin ich. Als der Krieg aus ausbruch bin ich gewesen in meiner Heimatstadt und ich habe damals abgemacht meine Matura.
David Boder: Wie alt waren Sie da?
George Kaldore: Ich war damals 18 Jahre alt
David Boder: . Ah hm.
George Kaldore: Dann bin ich in die Hauptstadt Budapest, weil es ist schon gewesen in Ungarn die Juden Gesetze, was die ungarische Regierung hat eingebracht in Ungarn. Ich bin überhaupt gekommen nach Budapest, um dort ein Fach aus zu lernen, weil ich mein weiteres Lernen nicht , weil ich nicht weiter studieren konnte, weil die ungarische Regierung in dem Juden Gesetz verboten hat Juden weiter zu studieren.
David Boder: Also sagen Sie – ein Moment, George – wie viele Leute waren in Ihrer Familie? Und wo waren Ihr Vater, Ihre Mutter und wie viele Brüder und wie viel Schwestern haben Sie gehabt?
George Kaldore: Mein Vater und Mutter und mein Bruder sind gewesen in der – in Szombathely, in Steinamanger , in meiner Heimatstadt. Ich allein bin gewesen in Budapest. Ich hab eine sehr alte Familie, die sind in meiner Heimatstadt. Mein Vater hat ein Geschäft gehabt, das in neun und dreißig (39) das hundert (100) jährige Jubiläum gehabt hat.
David Boder: Was für ein Geschäft hat er gehabt?
George Kaldore: Mein Vater hat gehabt ein Kleidergeschäft. Es war in Szombathely und es war was er von seinem Vater und der wieder von seinem Vater, und so weiter, hm, von seinem Vater er..... er ..... ererbt hatte ja.. Ich habe mir ausgelernt in Budapest ein Fach der Weberei und Strickerei und nach dem in neunzehn hundert vierzig bin ich eingerückt worden zu dem ungarischen Arbeitsdienst. Das heißt in Ungarn – da sind alle Juden herein gegangen in ein Arbeitslager, was man genannt hat Ungarischen Arbeitsdienst. Dort sind wir gegangen in unserer eigenen Kleidung und wir haben gemacht Festungen und Flugplätze für die deutschen und ungarischen Soldaten und für das ungarische Amt.
David Boder: Waren dort in dem Lager die SS oder die Ungarn?
George Kaldore: Nein, dort waren nur die ungarischen Offiziere, welche haben uns sehr schlecht aufgenommen. Wir haben, hm, Essen haben wir bekommen dort, aber so schlafen, da waren wir zusammen in einem, in einem großen Saal sehr viele. Und nachdem hat man uns gezwungen zu der Arbeit und es waren solche Offiziere, die haben sehr viel geschlagen auch. Nachdem habe ich abgerüstet und bin herein gegangen in ein Kriegswerk, wo ich habe in meinem Fach weiter gemacht.
David Boder: Was heißt, Sie haben abgerüstet?
George Kaldore: Das heißt, von die Soldaten hat man mich weg gelassen auf einen Urlaub und herein gesetzt in ein Werk, einem so genannten Kriegswerk, wo wir haben gemacht für die ungarischen und die deutschen Soldaten Pullover, Handschuhe und warme Sachen für die Front.
David Boder: Also warten Sie mal! Sie waren im Arbeitsdienst, wo man Sie genommen hat quasi als Soldat, nicht wahr?
George Kaldore: Als Soldat.
David Boder: Aber Juden durften nicht Soldaten sein.....
George Kaldore: Ja, Juden durften nicht Soldaten sein.
David Boder: ... und so hat man Sie einberufen? Wie alt waren Sie?
George Kaldore: Damals war ich zwanzig Jahre.
David Boder: Also wären Sie sonst Soldat gewesen?
George Kaldore: Ja.
David Boder: Und so hat man Sie einberufen.
George Kaldore: Einberufen als Arbeitsdienstlicher.
David Boder: Und dann hat man Sie beurlaubt.
George Kaldore: Ja beurlaubt. Und dort bin ich gewesen ...
David Boder: Wo war das?
George Kaldore: ... in dem, hm, Betrieb, so sie haben gemacht Handschuhe und Schals und warme Sachen für die Soldaten für den Winter und bin ich gewesen bis, hm, vier und vierzig (44). Im vier und vierzigsten (44.) Jahr ist in Ungarn herein gekommen die Deutschen, am 8. März. An diesem Tag ist es gewesen ein Bitterer, es ist gewesen ein Sonntag und wir haben gesehen in Budapest auf die Strassen – es kommen herein Tanks und deutsche SS Männer und deutsche Soldaten. Ich bin noch nach Hause gegangen an dem Abend mit dem Zug, man hat schon nicht mehr gekonnt nach Hause gehen, aber ich mit christlicher Schriften bin nach Hause gegangen, meine Mutter sehen und was zu Hause ist.
David Boder: Wieso haben Sie christliche Schriften gehabt?
George Kaldore: Ich habe bekommen die christlichen Schriften von der zionistischen Organisation, zu der ich früher gehört habe und die haben schon damals gemacht die christlichen Dokumente, die so genannten falschen Papiere, arische Papiere. Wie ich bin nach Hause gegangen war ich zu Hause nur einen Tag und meine Mutter hat das gespürt und da hat sie mir gesagt: „Mein lieber Sohn, ich sehe dich zum letzten Mal.“ Und da hab ich gesagt meiner Mutter: „Nein, meine Mutter, ich werde sein da zu Hause auf Seder, .....ist nicht weit Seder, Pesach und ich werde sein zusammen mit Dir.“ Aber sie hat nur geweint und ich bin weg gegangen und habe meine Mutter nicht mehr gesehen. Ich war damals in Budapest und in Budapest haben wir schon große 10 Zentimeter im Durchmesser messende Sterne getragen auf der Strasse. Wir konnten nicht herein gehen in die Konditoreien, in die Geschäfte. Wir haben gehabt zwei (2) Stunden um einzukaufen die Sachen. Damals ist gekommen die große Plakate auf der Strasse, dass alle Juden von 18 Jahre an einzurücken zur Arbeitsdienst. Ich bin herein gegangen zum Arbeitsdienst – von Budapest nicht weit - in Hatvan.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, müssen Sie eigentlich?
George Kaldore: Ja, sie müssen – auf Plakaten – Mobilisation für jüdische Arbeitsdienste. Ich bin herein gegangen im Juni, hab dort aufgenommen meine, mein so genanntes Soldatenbuch,das B-Buch und bin gewesen dort nur eine ganz kurze Zeit, weil man hat uns geschickt weiter von dort. Aber wir sind nicht weit gekommen. Zehn (10) Kilometer von dort in einer kleinen Stadt, von (unverständlich), Hatvan sind wir dort eingetroffen um zwölf (12) Uhr. Es war ein Fliegeralarm. Die Gendarmerie, die ungarische Gendarmerie .....
David Boder: In welchem Jahr war das?
George Kaldore: Das war im Jahr vier und vierzig (44) Juni. Die ungarische Gendarmerie ist gestanden bei der Bahn und hat gesagt – mit Gewehr und mit Stöcken – und hat gesagt: „Juden alles herunter kommen“. Wir haben uns gedacht, vielleicht treiben sie uns herein in einen Bunker, weil es war ja Fliegeralarm. Die englischen Flugzeuge sind gekommen. Man treibt herein in einen Bunker oder auf eine Wiese heraus, dass wir sollen nicht stehen auf dem Bahnhof. Man hat uns aber nicht auf eine Wiese gebracht, sondern von dort in zwei (2) Minuten sind wir gewesen in einer Zuckerfabrik. Dort ein Ghetto, das kleine Ghetto – gewesen das kleine Ghetto, wo die Juden von der Stadt gewohnt haben. Das war schon – die Juden haben schon zusammen gewohnt in dem ... in einem ... in dieser Fabrik. Wir sind an ..... angekommen dort. Es war ganz dunkel. Es hat geheißen, alle sollen das Gepäck herunter legen auf die Erde und wir sollen sich niedersetzen und keiner soll ein Wort nicht sagen. Keiner soll etwas zerreißen – Geld oder Dokumente – jeder soll sein ganz still.
David Boder: Hm. Wie viele Leute waren sie?
George Kaldore: Wir waren dort hundert fünfzig (150) von dem Arbeitsdienst. Wir haben nur das gesehen, dass diese andere Reihe sind wieder gewesen die Päckel, so was wir schon gekannt haben, das sind gewesen von anderer Arbeitsdienst-Leute die Päckel. Wir sind dort gesessen eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde lang, dann hat man geblasen der Fliegeralarm ist zu Ende. Dann ist gekommen ein deutscher Offizier mit ungarischem Offizier und Polizeimenschen – mitgekommen ein jüdischer
David Boder: Hm.
George Kaldore: ....mitgekommen ist ein jüdischer Polizeimann und haben uns erklärt, dass wir dort alle Wertsachen und alles, was wir bei uns haben an Dokumenten, sollen wir legen auf die Erde. Wir haben das getan. Wir haben doch gar nicht gewusst, was mit uns passieren wird weiter. Es sind gekommen die Gendarmerie und haben raus gesucht in die Taschen, was wir noch drinnen haben. Wir haben ja gar nichts gehabt. Wir haben Angst gehabt, denn wir haben gewusst, wenn wir nicht abgeben, bekommen wir einen großen Schlag ..... Schläge. Wir haben das auch abgegeben und sie haben das genommen für sich. Wir haben das selbst mit unseren Augen gesehen, dass sie legen das herein in ihre eigenen Taschen. Nachdem, dass wir unsere Sachen abgegeben haben, hat der ungarische Offizier ungarisch gesagt und nachdem ist gekommen der deutsche Offizier, der nicht einmal ein deutscher Offizier war, sondern ein ungarischer Offizier, der sogenannte Zöldy – Kapitan Zöldy – was gemacht hat in (unverständlich – klingt wie Novisdan) die Unruhe Politik, die Programme, was die ganze Welt gesprochen hat davon. Es ist gewesen der deutsche SS Mann und hat uns gesagt: „Juden, ihr seid jetzt da im Ghetto. Wir werden uns übertragen in ein Arbeitslager. Ihr werdet dort arbeiten und ihr sollt euch gut auf .. enthalten. Jetzt geht ihr herein in diese Baracke, da werdet ihr bleiben bis in der Früh. Und in der Früh werdet ihr weiter wissen, was mit dir ... mir euch geschieht.“ In der Früh um sechs (6) Uhr sind aufgestanden die Juden in dem Lager, das heißt – nicht in dem Lager, im Ghetto – und wir haben bekommen eine warme Krautsuppe und wir sehen, dass die Juden packen. Es ist gekommen ein Polizei und sie sagen, was ist los da im Ghetto und sagen, heute wird das ganze Ghetto abtransportiert werden. Gestern ist gegangen ein Transport und heute gehen wir – der Rest. Es ist gekommen wieder der SS Offizier und hat gesagt, wer nicht Jude ist - wer ein anderer Staatsbürger ist und nicht ein ungarischer Staatsbürger ist, soll sich melden.
David Boder: So – Juden oder nicht Juden?
George Kaldore: Auch Juden, wer nicht, hm, ein, ein ungarischer Staatsbürger ist. Es sind hervor getreten drei (3) Menschen. Einer mit einem schwedischen Pass, er ist gegangen zu ihm und man hat ihn weg getragen.
David Boder: Was ist mit ihm passiert? Man hat ihn weg geführt?
George Kaldore: Weg geführt, ja. Zwei (2) Juden sind gegangen, sie haben gesagt, ‚wir sind Christen’. Da hat er gesagt: ‚Ihre Dokumente?’ Da haben sie gesagt: ‚Du hast uns gestern weg genommen die Dokumente.’ Da hat er gesagt: ‚Ich hab nichts weg genommen – kein Dokument. Ihr habt es mir gegeben die Dokumente. Kommt her, ich werd euch suchen .... untersuchen, ob ihr seid Christen oder nicht.’ Und er geht hin und so, dass es alle sehen sollen, hat er gesehen die Rasse. Hat er gesehen die Augen, die Haare, das Gesicht. Dann sagt er: ‚Mein Lieber, es kann sein, du bist jetzt ein Christ, dass du bist ein getaufter Christ, aber dein Vater ist gewesen ein Jud und du bist auch ein Jud.’ Und hat ihn schon geschlagen mit dem Knüppel, den er hat in der Hand gehabt.
David Boder: Und er hat nur das Gesicht untersucht, die Augen und das Gesicht und sonst nichts?
George Kaldore: Er hat gar nichts Anderes untersucht, nur das Gesicht und er hat gesagt: ‚Du bist nicht von der Rasse von – von der Mongol, Du bist eine Rasse – eine jüdische Rasse.’ Wir sind nicht geblieben dort lange Zeit im Ghetto.
David Boder: Warum Mongol?
George Kaldore: Die ungarische Rasse gehört zu der mongolischen Rasse.
David Boder: Ja. Und?
George Kaldore: Wir sind nicht lange geblieben dort im Ghetto, wir sind geblieben dort bis zwölf (12) Uhr. Das heißt zwölf (12) Stunden sind wir im Ganzen gewesen im Ghetto. Um zwölf (12) Uhr hat es geheißen, alle nehmen die Säcke, das wir noch gehabt haben und, hm, dann zur Kontrolle. Bei der Kontrolle hat man alle guten Sachen heraus genommen in, in ....... von die Päckel. Wir haben ja gar nichts gehabt, wie sind ein ..., wir sind die ...herein gegangen zu dem ungarischen Arbeitsdienst, wir haben mit genommen ein Kleid und Unterwäsche und solche Sachen, was wir haben gebraucht bei dem ungarischen Arbeitsdienst zu arbeiten. Wir haben geglaubt man wird uns nachschicken solche Sachen, wir bleiben ja in Ungarn. Und ohne etwas zu essen und ohne zu trinken, sind wir herein gestoßen worden in die Wagons – fünf und achtzig Menschen in einen Wagon – und der Zug ist gestanden dort. Ein langer Zug – nicht ein ungarischer Zug, sondern deutsche Reichsbahn ist gestanden dort auf der ungarischen Station.
David Boder: Von wo hat man so viele Menschen genommen, sie sagen, es waren im Ganzen hundert zwanzig (120).
George Kaldore: Hundert zwanzig (120) sind wir gewesen vom Arbeitsdienst, aber im Ghetto sind gewesen von Umgebung von Budapest die Menschen, das heißt von Hatvan und von Hatvan die Umgebung. Es sind gewesen dort ungefähr zwei, drei tausend (2, 3000) Menschen.
David Boder: Ah hm!
George Kaldore: Man hat uns gesagt, .... um zwölf Uhr sind wir herein gegangen in die Wagons. Die Wagons sind bald abge ... plombt, abgeplombt geworden und erstens hat man genannt einen als Kommandant für den Wagon. Und man hat gar nichts Wasser und gar nichts herein gegeben. Die ungarische Gendarmerie mit der Polizei ist gestanden neben den Wagons. Und sie sind gegangen mit den Gewehren und keiner hat nicht können heraus von die Wagons.
David Boder: Ja.
George Kaldore: Keiner .... nur drinnen gesessen und wir sind gesessen und wir haben geglaubt, wo man uns hin fuhren wird. Einer hat gesagt man wird uns fuhren nach Österreich; der Andere hat gesagt man wird uns führen durch Ungarn, man wird uns führen in den deutschen Arbeitsdienst. Aber wir ungarischen Juden, wir waren diese Juden, die haben nichts gewusst von Auschwitz – wir haben nichts gehört vom Radio von Auschwitz und wenn gekommen sind die polnischen Juden und die deutschen Juden – haben wir gesagt: ‚Nein, das kann nicht sein – das kann nicht sein, dass man verbrennt deutsche und polnische Juden in Auschwitz.’ Wir haben das nicht geglaubt.
David Boder: Was haben Sie das vom Radio gesagt?
George Kaldore: Wir haben nichts gehört vom Radio – im Radio von Auschwitz. Wir haben im Geheimnis gehört vom Londoner Radio. Aber das Londoner Radio hat auch nichts gesagt, dass man verbrennt Juden. Wir haben geglaubt, das ist doch immer eine Propaganda. Wir haben das nicht geglaubt, dass man verbrennt Juden. Und, hm, um vier (4) Uhr nachmittags ist der Zug abgefahren. Gefahren nach, hm, Süden herauf – nach Miskolc. In Miskolc sind wir gewesen in der Nacht. In Miskolc hat man zugegeben noch der Ghetto noch von Miskolc .... vom Ghetto noch von Miskolc. Von Miskolc sind wir abgefahren um zwölf (12) Uhr in der Nacht und auf einer Station, noch auf der ungarischen Seite, ist der Zug etwas langsamer gegangen. Von dem Zug die Kameraden haben gesagt: ‚Kinder man kann uns noch retten. Wir springen heraus von den Wagons.’
David Boder: Aber sie waren doch plombiert?
George Kaldore: Ja, es war plombiert, aber oben diese Wagons sind die Ketterl. Und wir haben gehabt eine kleine, ....... diese, diese Ketterl von Eisen gemacht ...
David Boder: Gitter?
George Kaldore: Gitter von Eisen gemacht, ja. Und wir haben gehabt eine kleine Säge und wir haben abgesegelt .....
David Boder: Abgesägt.
George Kaldore: Wir haben abgesägt und fünf (5) Menschen von unserem Wagon sind heraus gesprungen. Und die fünf (5) Menschen, nachdem wir nach Hause gekommen sind vom Lager, haben wir gesprochen mit diesen Menschen und diese Menschen sind gerettet geworden. Man hat sie nicht gesehen. Die Wagons hat man ... sind gewesen, hm, ungarische Gendarmerie bis zu der ungarischen slowakischen Grenze bis Kosice. Die ungarische Gendarmerie ist gesessen oben auf dem Dach und sie haben von da gesehen, was in den Wagons geschieht. Bis Kosice hat man gar nicht aufgemacht die Wagons.
George Kaldore: Das ist gewesen vier und zwanzig (24) Stunden zu fahren. Wir sind in die Wagons .... Einer ist gestanden, der Zweite ist gelegen; schon mit einem großen Bart die Menschen – Menschen, die als wilde Tiere ausgeschaut. Schon sind gewesen in unserem Wagon zwei tote Menschen, gewesen sind drei, vier (3,4), die sind ganz verrückt geworden, sie haben schon nicht gekonnt sprechen von dem Durst. Und in Kosice hat man aufgemacht die Wagons, da ist herein gekommen schon die SS Polizei und die deutsche Gendarmerie; nicht SS sondern deutsche Gendarmerie. Man hat herein gegeben in jeden Wagon ungefähr zehn (10) Liter Wasser ..... für 80 Menschen, so dass jeder einer Mensch hat bekommen ein ganz bisschen zu trinken und ......
David Boder: Wie hat man das Wasser gegeben?
George Kaldore: Das Wasser hat man gebracht in einem Keiler, in einem , hm, ....
David Boder: Kessel.
George Kaldore: ... in einem Kessel, in einem so einem Kessel hat man gebracht Wasser und den Kessel hat man dann heraus genommen.
David Boder: Und wie hat man getrunken?
George Kaldore: Man hat getrunken von einem kleinen Glas von zwei (2) Dezi.
David Boder: Von zwei (2)?
George Kaldore: Von zwei (2) Dezi.
David Boder: Gramm?
George Kaldore: Von zwei (2) Dezigramm
David Boder: Haben sie jedem gegeben das selbe Glas?
George Kaldore: Man hat nicht Jedem gegeben das selbe Glas. Man hat sich dort gestoßen für das Wasser, Einer hat mehr getrunken, der Andere hat gar nichts getrunken. Und, hm, man hat herunter genommen von dem Wagon die toten Menschen dort. Gekommen ist wieder der ungarische Offizier bei der Grenze und bei der Grenze in Kosice hat man uns gesagt: „ Wer sich fühlt , dass er nicht Jude, soll herunter kommen.’ Aber es war schon kein Mensch, der hat nicht gewollt Jude sein – Jude war schon Jude - und alle zusammen sind wir gefahren in die Wagons weiter. Der Wagon ist gefahren durch die Slowakei . In der Slowakei bei die Deutschen ist gewesen so, der Deutsche ist herein gekommen eine Station nach der ungarischen Grenze und er hat gesagt: „Juden, ich weiß, ihr hab noch bei euch Gulden, ich habt noch bei euch ungarisches Geld. Ihr werdet geführt an einen Ort, wo man nicht nützen kann den Gulden, wo man nicht nützen kann das Essen, gar nichts nützen kann – ihr werdet alles bekommen. Ihr sollt uns geben Essen, ihr sollt uns geben Geld ...
David Boder: Was für Essen?
George Kaldore: So Essen, Konserven und Geld und Gulden und Kleider. Und einer wollte Handschuhe und der Andere hat gebeten für Strümpfe von uns, gute Strümpfe. Sie haben alle gewusst, die Juden haben die besten Sachen.
David Boder: Haben denn die Juden die besten Sachen gehabt?
George Kaldore: Ja,. Wir haben gehabt noch damals die besten Sachen, wir haben das von daheim noch mit genommen. Und dafür – sie haben uns gesagt, sie geben uns .....
David Boder: Was heißt die besten Sachen? Bessere Sachen, als die Christen gehabt haben oder die Juden haben ihre besten Sachen mitgenommen?
George Kaldore: Die Juden haben die besten Sachen mitgenommen.
David Boder: Ihre eigenen Sachen?
George Kaldore: Die eigenen Sachen, ja, ja. Und dafür haben sie gesagt, wenn ihr gibt das uns, dann kriegt ihr Wasser. Und die Juden haben noch genommen Geld und wir haben bekommen von ihnen noch Wasser, ein wenig Wasser.
David Boder: Und die Juden haben noch Geld gehabt?
George Kaldore: Die Juden haben noch ... nach der Untersuchung – haben sie noch immer Geld gehabt in den Taschen. Und wir sind weiter gefahren – von der Slowakei nach Polen. In Polen - in Krakau haben wir gefragt die Deutschen, wir haben heraus geschaut dort bei den kleinen Fenster, was ist schon geworden zu gemacht in Kosice, wir haben ein bisserl herausgeschaut und gefragt, was wird mit uns sein. Das haben die Lokomotisten gesagt, die schon Deutsche waren, denn Krakau war schon eine besetzte Stadt – und da haben sie gesagt zu uns: ‚Ihr geht nach Birkenau.’ Wir haben nicht gewusst was ist Birkenau, Birkenau haben wir gedacht, das ist der Himmel, er hat uns gezeigt, dass es brennt und wir haben gar nichts gewusst was und wohin wir gehen.
David Boder: Haben Sie gedacht, es ist etwas Gutes oder etwas Schlechtes?
George Kaldore: Nein, wir haben gedacht, das das ist was Schlechtes. Wir haben doch zwischen uns gesagt – die paar Menschen, die haben noch gekonnt denken, ..... weil die Meisten haben schon gar nicht mehr gekonnten denken. Es waren .....
David Boder: Wie alt waren Sie damals?
George Kaldore: Ich war damals, hm, drei und zwanzig (23) Jahre alt.
David Boder: Aha. Und jetzt sind sie ?
George Kaldore: Und jetzt bin ich über drei und zwanzig (23).
David Boder: Und das war In welchem Jahr? In fünf und vierzig (45)?
George Kaldore: Nein, das war in dem .... das war im Jahr vier und vierzig (44). Oh ja, ich war zwei und zwanzig (22) Jahre alt damals.
David Boder: Weiter, George.
George Kaldore: Ich war zwei und zwanzig (22) Jahre alt. Die Menschen waren schon, die fünf und achtzig Menschen, die haben nicht gekonnt heraus gehen von den Wagons, sie haben dort gemusst ihre Sachen erledigen in den Wagons .... so.
David Boder: Was meine Sie damit?
George Kaldore: Kleine Sachen ja, Toilettensache erledigen dort.
David Boder: Also was haben sie gemacht, wenn sie haben müssen was tun – sie hatten keine Toilette im Wagon?
George Kaldore: Ja, das ist gewesen ein Wagon für Tiere. Diese Viehwagons waren das. Wir haben genommen die (unverständlich), diese Teller, die wir haben mitgenommen zum Essen und wir haben in den herein gemacht und das herausgeworfen in dem Fenster. Und es war stinkend in dem Wagon, es war warm und wir haben nicht gehabt Wasser zu trinken. Und schon Essen was wir haben noch mitgenommen – ein bisserl was in den Säcken noch versteckt war, war auch schon nicht da. Und so sind wir angekommen in Auschwitz ..... und von Auschwitz ist es zwei (2 km) Kilometer nach Birkenau – diese Station. Man hat uns genommen auf eine solches Bahngeleise, wo nur ein Zug gestanden ist – unser Zug. Wir sind angekommen und ..... nachdem wir sind angekommen nach Birkenau auf dem Geleise, haben wir gesehen Menschen in blau weißen gestreiften Anzüge, sie sind gelaufen zu der Bahn und sagen jiddisch, dass: ‚Jüd, Ihr sollt runter steigen von der Bahn mit allem – ihr sollt herunter steigen mit alles und aufreihen.’ Wir sind herunter gestiegen ....
David Boder: Waren das jüdische Capos?
George Kaldore: Das war nicht jüdisches Gestapo. Das war ein Kommando, was wir später erst gewusst haben, das war das sogenannte Kanada Kommando.
David Boder: Und was war das?
George Kaldore: Das war das Kommando was übergenommen hat die Transporte was angekommen sind.
David Boder: Warum hat man sie genannt Kanada Kommando?
George Kaldore: Kanada, weil die haben gehabt Essen, weil sie haben von dort gestohlen,weil sie haben getragen die Sachen von Juden, was in die Transporte waren auf den Wagons. Die Sachen getragen in das Magazin und sie haben dort sehr viel Essen gehabt.
David Boder: Waren sie jüdisch ... Juden?
George Kaldore: Juden, ja, ja, das waren Juden, deportierte Juden, die in diesem Kommando gearbeitet haben. Und die haben alle gut ausgeschaut, weil die haben gegessen von dem was die Transporte gebracht haben, was sie dort noch gefunden haben. Wir sind dort angekommen und wir haben gesehen es laufen dort herum Kinder, ganz kleine Kinder und Mütter und, und ganz narrische Menschen, die Haare ganz zerrottet und mit großem Bart und da laufen Menschen mit großem Bart dort herum um unsere Menschen von die Wagons. Und man sagt uns, wir sollen stehen, wir sollen stehen in der Reihe und ins Bad hinein gehen. Und wir sehen dort eine große Tafel, da ist ausgeschrieben bei dem Lager „Arbeit macht frei“. Wir gehen zu dem Tor und steht dort ein SS Oberarzt, von dem wir später gewusst haben ..... ge.. gehört haben den Namen – ein Doktor Mengele.
David Boder: Was ist passiert mit ihm?
George Kaldore: Wo passiert?
David Boder: Ich meine was ist passiert? Ist er arretiert?
George Kaldore: Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, er ist verhaftet. Er ist vor dem Gesetz in München. Ich weiß es nicht bestimmt aber. Und er ist gestanden dort und er hat gesagt für unsere Menschen: „ Ihr geht zur Arbeit und wer fühlt sich stark zur Arbeit soll er gehen und wer fühlt sich nicht so stark zur Arbeit zu gehen, so gehen zu Fuß, soll gehen auf der anderen Seite und sie werden ihn tragen mit einem Auto und er wird gehen, auf einen anderen Ort wird er kommen, wo leichtere Arbeit, er wird nicht so schwer arbeiten.’ Und es sind gegangen die Mütter mit kleine Kinder und gegangen Frauen und alte Menschen. Und von uns junge Menschen, die haben gesagt: ‚Es tut weh der Fuß, ich kann nicht gehen, ich weiß nicht wieviel ich gehen muss und wir sind gegangen. Und, hm, von den ganzen vier tausend (4000) vom Transport, wie sind geblieben tausend (1000) Menschen.
David Boder: Sind sie mitgegangen mit die Schwachen auch?
George Kaldore: Ich bin nicht gegangen mit den Schwachen. Ich bin mitgegangen mit die aussortierten ... mit den aussortierten Menschen .....
David Boder: Warum?
George Kaldore: Ich hab mich ..... ich hab in mir gespürt noch, noch Kraft zu der Arbeit. Meine Seele war noch stark, ich habe gespürt, dass ich kann noch arbeiten. Und wenn man mich zu der Arbeit führt, kann ich das vielleicht noch aushalten bei der Arbeit. Und ich bin gegangen, hm, mit dem Transport und man hat uns geführt herein in den Waschraum. In dem Waschraum ist schon gewesen die SS Polizei, aber bevor wir sind herein gegangen in diesen Waschraum, muss ich noch sagen, da ist gewesen eine Musik .... wir hören Musik. Es ist gewesen Häftlinge haben gespielt dort die Trompeten, ein ganzes Musik Orchester, gespielt Jazz Musik. Ja und wir fragen, was ist da? Ja, man hat uns erzählt, es kommt ein Transport und sie spielen, dass man soll gar nichts wissen. Und die Männer sagen uns, wir sollen nicht so viel nachfragen. Und wir sehen laufen Menschen und fragen: „Jüd, von wo kimmt er?“ Und Ungarische fragen in ungarisch. Und wir fragen nur ein Wort: “Juden kann man da trinken das Wasser?“ „Ja, ihr könnt trinken, aber ihr sollt nicht viel trinken davon.“ Wir gehen herein in den Waschraum und da ist dort schon die SS mit die polnische Capo, das polnische, nicht jüdische Capos – und sie stehen dort: „Juden, ihr sollt alles abziehen, ihr bekommt ganz neue Kleider. Wir sollen alles ausziehen und da lassen. Ganz nackert, ihr sollt nur Eure Schuhe und den Hosenträger oder der Riemen was für Hemd und Hosen. Nachdem sind wir weiter gegangen in den zweiten (2.) Raum. Also wir sind weiter gegangen in den zweiten (2.) Raum, wo schon gesessen sind auf einer langen Bank, hm, Juden, polnische Juden und die was gehabt haben in der Hand ...... Haarschneidemaschinen. Man ht uns ganz abrasiert, das heißt, wo wir Haare gehabt haben, hat man mit der Maschine ganz abgeschnitten; und unsere Haare, unseren Bart abgeschnitten und so sind wir weiter gegangen bei der Tür. Bei der Tür ist gestanden schon ein Capo, was hat uns herein geschaut in den Mund, ob wir haben nichts in dem Mund, das heißt, wir haben nichts versteckt in dem Mund, Gulden oder andere Diamanten oder solche Sachen, was wert ist.
David Boder: Und ob sie goldene Zähne gehabt haben?
George Kaldore: Die goldenen Zähne sind noch geblieben in der Zeit. Und wir sind weiter gegangen in den Infektionsraum auf der unreinen Seite. Wir haben ... man hat uns ganz desinfiziert. Wir haben bekommen ein kleines Stückchen Seife und eine Dusche ist gewesen dort und .....
David Boder: Eine Wasserdusche?
George Kaldore: Eine Wasserdusche, ja, das war eine Wasserdusche .... ist gewesen dort ein warmes Dusch mit einem kleine Stückchen Seife bekommen und wir haben uns dort gewaschen und ich habe schon gespürt, hm, dass ich werd sein ein ganz anderer Mensch. Ich habe schon zurück bekommen ein bisschen von meiner Stärke. Essen haben wir noch gar nichts bekommen und wir haben getrunken von dem Wasser, was dort war.
David Boder: Von der Dusche?
George Kaldore: Von der Dusche, weil die Dusche ist gewesen auf der deutschen Mode. Wir bekommen ganz heißes Wasser, das heiße Wasser ist gegangen in ganz kaltes Wasser. Das heißt deutsches Solnar Bad.
David Boder: Wie heißt das? Wieso, da war kaltes Wasser .....
George Kaldore: Nein, von der Dusche ist gekommen das heiße Wasser. Und man hat so gedreht drinnen das deutsche ...... das heiße Wasser, dass es ist gekommen heiß und langsam kühler – bis ganz kaltes Wasser. Und nachdem wir nach dem Baden ganz rein hat man uns mit Spiritus ganz abgewaschen .....
David Boder: Wer hat das getan?
George Kaldore: Das haben dort die Capos gemacht, die haben sich dort beschäftigt in dem Waschraum und weiter gegangen auf der reinen Seite.
David Boder: Waren die Capos anständig dabei?
George Kaldore: Das waren jüdische Capos und die jüdischen Capos haben dort nicht geschlagen. Sie waren anständig und haben uns mit geholfen.
David Boder: Was für ein Lager war das?
George Kaldore: Das war in Au ......, das war im Zentrallager Birkenau.
David Boder: Aha, Birkenau.
George Kaldore: Wenn man darf wissen, dass Birkenau war das Zentrallager; in Auschwitz war schon ein Arbeitslager.
David Boder: Und die Krematorien?
George Kaldore: Die waren in Birkenau.
David Boder: Aha.
George Kaldore: Die waren nicht in Auschwitz. Man nennt das nur Auschwitz. Und nachdem wir sind gegangen in die reine Seite und dort waren schon die Kleider. Das heißt, Kleider, die gestreiften, blau weißen Anzüge, wie ich das gesehen habe im Film Sing-Sing, wie die ausgeschaut haben mit die blau weißen Anzüge. Lange Hosen oder kurze Hosen, so wie es gefallen ist. Ein kleiner Bursche hat bekommen eine lange Hose, ein Großer hat bekommen eine kleinere Hose mit einem kleineren Jackett, das ist gemacht von Leinwand. Ganz kalte Sachen waren das, hm, so dass im Juni, wie wir dort angekommen sind, war ein sehr kaltes Wetter noch und wir haben da, für uns war es sehr kalt noch. Und die Schuhe haben wir noch in der Hand gehabt, die was haben Stiefeln gehabt, die Stiefeln hat man weggenommen und, hm, anstatt die Stiefeln hat man gegeben hölzerne Schuhe. Und wir haben das angezogen. Allen hat man gegeben noch eine Unterhose mit einem Hemd, aber ganz schöne Sachen waren das, was man uns gegeben hat, man kann sagen neue Sachen. Das sind gewesen die Unterhosen und Hemden, was man weggenommen ....... weggegeben hat von den Transporten, was gekommen sind. Von dort, von dem (unverständlich) sind wir heraus gegangen und schon gestanden in einer Reihe und rein gegangen in einen großen Block.
David Boder: Und was hat mit den Leuten passiert, wissen Sie, die auf der anderen Seite gegangen sind?
George Kaldore: Damals haben wir noch gar nichts gewusst. Wir haben gefragt, was ist mit diesen Leuten, wir haben gar nichts gewusst. Wir sind nur gegangen und gegangen und haben gar nichts gewusst von den Menschen. Wir sind herein gegangen ......
David Boder: Aber die Krematorien waren in Birkenau.
George Kaldore: Die Krematorien waren da, ja. Bald werd ich von diesen sprechen. Das war schon am Abend, was ich jetzt sag, das war schon acht Uhr am Abend wie wir sind, wie wir sind fertig geworden mit dem Baden.
David Boder: Hm.
George Kaldore: Nachdem wir sind herein gegangen in einen großen Raum, das hat geheißen Birkenau dreizehn (13) ......
David Boder: Ah hm.
George Kaldore: ...... Block. Das ist gewesen das Zigeuner Lager. Dort haben früher gewohnt die Zigeuner. Das sind nicht gewesen Juden; nur das sind gewesen diese Zigeuner, welche gewohnt haben in Ungarn. Die musikal...., die Musikanten Zigeuner, von Deutschland die Zigeuner, die sind nicht gewesen die sogenannte Rasse von die Deutschen. Das sind nicht gewesen die deutsche Rasse. Rassen sind auch gewesen dort und aber die sind gegangen angezogen wie ..... in sehr komische Kleider, in solche große Hut, was man hat weggenommen von den Rabbinern, was man hat weggenommen von den Rabbinern, diese chassidischen Hüte, und da sind sie gegangen .......
David Boder: Die Zigeuner?
George Kaldore: ... die Zigeuner. Und angezogen, hm, ...... Anzüge, die sind gemacht worden auf der anderen Seite .... auf der .... rückwärts mit einem roten Kreuz, einen großen gestreiften roten Kreuz.
David Boder: Warum?
George Kaldore: Dass sie nicht heraus fliehen vom Lager. Das war ein Zeichen, dass sie sind auch Häftlinge, da hat geheißen, sie sind Häftlinge.
David Boder: Also sagen Sie mir, waren die Frauen mit den Zigeunern?
George Kaldore: Die Zigeuner waren zusammen mit den Frauen, die Kinder, sie haben das gesehen auch Zigeuner Frauen, was sind gewesen schwanger.
David Boder: Die waren alle im selben Block?
George Kaldore: Alle im selben Block zusammen gelebt. Unser Block Ältester ist gewesen auch ein Zigeuner. Und es geheißen: ‚Ihr sollt euch niederlegen.’ Es sind gewesen tausend fünf hundert (1500) Menschen, die geblieben sind von den vier tausend fünf hundert (4500) von dem Transport. Alle waren in einem ... in einem Block.
David Boder: Und wieviel Zigeuner waren dort?
George Kaldore: Zigeuner waren schon fort, nur der Block Älteste mit seiner großen Familie. Über den Block ich muss erzählen noch, dass das Lager Birkenau war vor dem Krieg eine ...... eine ..... sogenannte ... man hat es .... Reitsaal, dort waren Pferde vor dem Krieg.
David Boder: Ein Stadium (Rest unverständlich – beide sprechen)
George Kaldore: ... ein Pferde Reit Stadium. Man hat uns gesagt: ‚Juden legt Eure Gesichter auf die Erde, es wird schon passieren Euch nichts.’ Und wir haben geweint: ‚Menschen, bringt uns etwas zu trinken.’
David Boder: [In English] This concludes ...... this concludes Spool 97. We are going over to Spool 98. George... eh, George Kaldore being interviewed at the Camp Tradate, or the cooperative place Tradate for displaced Jews.
David Boder: This is Spool 98. Italy — the Castle Tradate between Milan and Como, in a camp of displaced persons, of the so-called Kibbutzim groups, or the Hashara, which is preparing the young people to go at one time or another to Palestine. The interviewee is George Kaldore, 23 (twenty three) from Hungary.
David Boder: [In German] Nun weiter, was?
George Kaldore: Ja, ich habe gelassen meine Erzählungen dort, dass, hm, dass es hat geheißen, wir wollen uns niederlegen dort, ein tausend fünf hundert (1500) Menschen in einem großen Saal und wir sollen, hm, dort ruhig bleiben ..... wir sollen dort ruhig bleiben bis kommt Einer und der wird uns sagen, was passieren wird.
David Boder: Entschuldigen Sie, ich möchte Sie eine Frage fragen. Wissen Sie, was mit den Zigeunern passiert hat?
George Kaldore: Ja, ich weiß. Es ist nach zwei (2) Monaten habe ich gehört – schon in dem anderen Lager, wo ich nach dem übertragen geworden bin, dass, hm, auf einer Nacht ist gewesen ein Appell und man hat gerufen alle Zigeuner raus. Und die Zigeuner sind heraus gekommen und alle Frauen, alle Kinder und die Zigeuner was dort geblieben sind, hat man diese Nacht verbrannt. Nur das ist nichts geblieben von die Zigeuner, keiner war mehr in dem Lager. Das weiß ich von die Erzählungen von die Kameraden, was gekommen sind von dort im Lager und uns erzählt haben.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
George Kaldore: Es ist gekommen herein ein Dolmetscher – es ist gewesen aufgeschrieben auf der linken Arm – ein ungarisch deutsch Dolmetscher mit einem Zigeuner und unserem Bock Ältesten. Er ist aufgestanden dort auf einem Fach und hat uns gehalten eine Rede. Er hat uns gesagt: ‚Juden, ihr seid gekommen nach Auschwitz, Birkenau. Das ist soweit ein Vernichtungslager, wer nicht ... wer nicht arbeiten kann, der wird da verbrennt. Und wer arbeiten kann wird, arbeiten bis er arbeiten kann. Da kannst du gar nichts behalten. Ich habe da gebracht jetzt eine Lampe’ – es ist noch herein gekommen ein SS Mann – ‚man wird alles mit der Lampe, es ist eine Röntgen Lampe, durch gesucht. Vielleicht habt ihr noch bei euch Gulden oder noch Wertsachen oder solche Sachen, was ihr dürft nicht haben. Das heißt, gar nichts bei euch haben.’
David Boder: Und wieso, wieso eine Röntgen Lampe?
George Kaldore: Ja, Röntgen Lampe, ich werd das bald sagen, wie das war. Und er hat noch gebracht dort Schraubenzieher und Hammer und er hat gesagt, wir sollen auch herunternehmen von die Schuhe, die, die Sohlen. ‚Vielleicht hab ihr dort etwas weggesteckt und das hat man nicht bemerkt, weil ..... wie ihr herein gekommen seid in den Block.’ Und er ist gekommen und die Juden haben herunter genommen die Sohlen. Und es ist noch immer gekommen Gold und noch immer gekommen Geld und ein Jude hatte herausgenommen ein Arbeitsbuch, ein ungarisches Arbeitsbuch. Und er hat gesagt: ‚Das ist mein Arbeitsbuch, ich bin ein Arbeiter und ich werde arbeiten.’ Und er hat gesagt: ‚Lass es nur da.’ Und Bilder von der Mutter und von dem Vater, was man hat noch gerettet die Juden, ich weiß nicht in die Schuhe oder im Mund oder wie .... ich kann mir das nicht einmal denken, wie nach einer solchen starken Untersuchung. Und er hat gesagt: ,Alles hat man schon abgegeben?’ Und da haben die Juden gesagt: ’ja.’ Dann hat er gesagt: ‚Ja, ich sehe, ihr seid ungarische Juden, sicher habt ihr gar nichts bei Euch. Die ungarischen Juden, die haben alle Angst. Ich werde Euch jetzt nicht untersuchen mit der Röntgen Lampe.’ Nachdem haben wir gewusst, es war keine Röntgen Lampe, es war ganz ordinare große Lampe, die er hat herein gebracht. Und er hat sich genommen das Gold und nachdem zwei Tage später haben wir gewusst, dass er mit den Gulden hat gekauft für die, von die polnische Arbeiter, was haben gearbeitet in dem Lager, die nicht gewohnt in dem Lager, sondern sind nur herein gekommen und von der Besetzung hat er gekauft dann dafür Brot und hat gekauft Schmalz und hat gegessen davon.
David Boder: Hat er denn sonst nicht genug zu essen bekommen?
George Kaldore: Nein, er hat nur bekommen die Ration. Er hat nur gehabt das Essen was er konnte weg stehlen von die Juden. Und er hat gesagt: ‚Bald werden sie bringen schwarzen Kaffee, jeder einer wird bekommen Kaffee.’ Und man hat auch gebracht den Kaffee und er hat gesagt: ‚Juden, ihr dürft nicht heraus gehen von dem, hm, Ort. Zwei (2) Schritte könnte ihr heraus gehen. Es steht da ein Box in dem Block drinnen, wo man kann die kleinen Toiletten Sachen machen. Und außer dem Block zwei Schritte, ist eine andere Box, wo man kann die großen Toiletten Sachen machen. Aber weiter sollt ihr nicht gehen, denn dort sind schon die Drahte und die SS Menschen in dem großen Turm, was sind gewesen mit die große Reflektoren und mit den Hunden, dann wenn ihr geht noch drei Schritte, dann haben sie ihn und schießen sie ihn bald ab.’ Und wir haben uns nieder gelegt auf der Erde, ohne Decken, ohne .... ohne alles und geschlafen. Das war die erste Nacht, dass wir konnten nach den Wagons ein bisschen schlafen. In der Früh um sechs (6) Uhr hat man schon geläutet zum Appell. Wir sind heraus gegangen, man hat uns gezählt, wieviel Menschen wir sind. Und man hat gesagt, jetzt werden die Menschen rein machen den Block. Wir haben gemusst aufwaschen den Block und wir haben bekommen zum Kehren und (unverständlich) ... ganz rein machen.
David Boder: Was haben Sie bekommen Besen und?
George Kaldore: Besen und .... hm, ja ... zum Reinemachen.
David Boder: ... und Lappen (beide sprechen – unverständlich)
George Kaldore: Ja, zum Reinemachen. Ja auch, hm, zum Aufräumen das Ganze. Und um 10 Uhr hat man gebracht die erste (1.) Suppe. Das hat geheißen diese deutsche Suppe – zusammen gekocht alles Mögliche. Man hat gegeben für 10 Menschen zusammen in einem großen Topf. Der Topf war schmutzig. Es war so ein Topf, was man hat von die Wagons heraus genommen von den Juden – ohne auszuwaschen. Wir haben gewusst, was man in diesen Töpfen gemacht hat, die Juden haben da ja herein gemacht in den Wagons und wir haben nicht gehabt ein Wasser das auszuwaschen. Und einige Menschen haben nicht gegessen. Ich hab gesagt: ‚Ich werd essen, was man mir geben wird.’ Denn das ist mein ganzes Essen, man kann das nicht essen .... aber ich werde es auch essen, weil ich weiß, wenn ich es nicht essen werde, werde ich nicht haben .... werde ich nicht haben die, die ..... die Kräfte dazu, dass ich soll das weiter machen die Arbeit. Und es sind wieder geworden zwei (2) Menschen – Zuckerkranke – sie sind so schlecht geworden, dass sie haben gesagt, sie brauchen Injektionen und man hat sie weg geführt. Man hat sie weg geführt und wir haben sie nicht gesehen mehr. Und schon um elf (11) Uhr haben wir uns getraut ein paar Schritte heraus zu machen – und wir haben gesehen, es brennt etwas. Es brennt, es brennt, es brennt. Am Vormittag um elf (11) Uhr wir haben gesehen Flammen und geriecht etwas Stinkendes. Wir haben gefragt von sie Zigeuner: ‚Was brennt denn da?’ Und sagen sie: ‚Ach, man verbrennt da die Kleider, was ihr habt gebracht, die Schmates, die solche Sachen, was man kann nicht benützen. Ihr sollt Euch nicht kümmern, was da verbrennt.’ Und nachdem hat man gesagt, ‚Jetzt sollt ihr euch niederlegen’. Wir haben gar nichts gemacht. Und es ist vergangen noch ein Tag. Noch ein Tag und dann ist gekommen ein SS, man hat gesagt wir sollen aufstehen. Die SS hat uns gesehen, durch gesehen und hat gesagt, es sollen da stehen welche waren Soldaten, welche waren vor dem Krieg Soldaten, welche sind starke Menschen für eine starke Arbeit. Und wir sind dort hin gestanden. Man hat zwei Gruppen gemacht – von die starken Menschen und von die nicht ganz starken Menschen .... und, hm .....
David Boder: Wo waren Sie gewesen?
George Kaldore: Ich war bei den starken Menschen. Und es sind gewesen bei uns zwei (2) dicke Menschen, zwei (2) ganz dicke Menschen, die waren hundert (100) Kilo. Und der SS Mann hat gesagt: ‚Na, Ihr seid stark?’ Und da haben sie gesagt: ‚Ja.’ ‚Na, ich will sehen ein Wette. Ihr sollt einen Kampf zwischen euch, so ein Box Match mit eine... ein Box Match – wer ist stärker, der wird gehen auf die Seite mit den Stärkeren und der Andere wird gehen auf die andere Seite.’ Und wir ... der Eine ist gekommen auf die Seite und wir Juden haben gelacht noch darauf. Sie haben, wir haben nicht gewusst, was wird sein weiter. Und die ..... und die Menschen, was waren die starken Menschen, hat man gestellt in der Reihe, wir sind gewesen schon fünf hundert (500).
David Boder: Was hat man mit die zwei (2) dicken Menschen passiert?
George Kaldore: Das wissen wir nicht, sie sind geblieben dort.
David Boder: Ah, man hat sie nicht gleich .....?
George Kaldore: Man hat sie nicht weg geführt, nein, und nachdem, hm, nach Monaten hab ich getroffen Einen, hm, dort in dem Arbeitslager, wo ich später war und der hat erzählt, dass man sie getragen nach Auschwitz ....
David Boder: Uebernommen hat ... (beide sprechen)
George Kaldore: Ja, nach Auschwitz in eine Fabrik zu arbeiten. Wir sind gegangen in sogenanntes Quarantäne Lager, das war Block eins (1) in dem ... dort in Birkenau. In dem Quarantäne Lager haben wir bekommen, hm, eine Decke für zwei (2) Menschen und dort waren schon einstöckige Betten, das heißt in einem Bett sind geschlafen zehn (10) Menschen. Das waren nicht Betten, das waren nur von Holz gemachte, hm, solche Pritschen. Da haben zehn (10) Menschen geschlafen mit fünf (5) Decken. Und damals sind zu gekommen Juden, polnische Juden, die haben wollen mit uns, hm, die Schuhe gewollt tauschen. Einer wollt geben ein Stückchen Brot und er gibt andere Schuhe. Und sie haben uns gesagt, die Schuhe sind da, wie so ein Leben. Wer hat Schuhe, der hat ein ganzes Leben, ja. Und wir haben nicht gewollt das Tauschen. Wir waren – man hat uns gesagt wir kommen in Quarantäne, weil in dem Zigeuner Lager war Scharlach. Und wir sind gewesen in dem Quarantäne Lager vier (4) Tage. Nachdem ist gekommen ein Befehl nach dem Appell, dass wir werden gehen alle weiter. So, dass die fünf hundert (500) Menschen sind gegangen in einer Reihe – so vier (4) zusammen in der Reihe und wir haben sich gehalten die Schulter. Vier Menschen auf dem ganzen Weg. Und gewesen .... gekommen ist mit uns zehn (10) SS Menschen mit Büchsen in der Hand und geführt durch Auschwitz durch die Strasse. Wir haben gesehen dort die Menschen, wir haben gesehen dort die Geschäfte. Menschen, die gingen auf der Strasse, die Pollaken dort, die Christlichen. Es ist gewesen solche, die haben geschaut traurig, es hat gegeben solche, die haben gelacht auf uns. Und wir sind gegangen von dort zehn (10) Kilometer und sind herein gegangen in ein Lager, das hat geheißen Buna Lager. Das ist gewesen von der Farben Industrie, I. G., von der großen Gesellschaft, das, hm, das Lager von einer Fabrik, synthetischer Gummi „Buna“. Und wir sind dort herein gegangen, der Block Älteste ist .... war gekommen und schnell auf den Appell Platz und hat gesagt: ‚Ihr sollt gleich gehen in den Waschraum.’ Und, ja, man hat uns herein geführt wieder in die Desinfektions-Baracke und hat uns wieder weggenommen diese Kleider, was wir haben bekommen und rein gegangen in diese Duschen und desinfiziert uns wieder und wir sind herausgekommen auf der reinen Seite. Dort ist wieder gestanden ein Arzt, der untersucht uns. Und wir bekommen schon ganz schlechte Sachen, wieder diese blau weiß gestreiften Sachen, aber ganz Schlechte, Zerrissene, Kleine und dann hat man uns herein geführt in einen Block, den Quarantäne Block. In den Quarantäne Block sind wir herein gegangen, hm, und dort hat man gesagt uns: ‚Menschen, ihr sollt da bleiben und von dem Block dürft ihr nicht heraus gehen bis ihr fertig eingeteilt werdet in dem Lager in die Kommandos.’ Weil wir sind ja gekommen von einem Ort, von einem Lager, wo Scharlach war. Und waren nicht – ja, warum wissen wir nicht, man hat uns eingeteilt in das Strafkommando. Das hat geheißen in einem Außenkommando, das hat gearbeitet außer dem Lager sechs (6) Kilometer. Wir haben gemacht Festungen für die Deutschen.
David Boder: Warum Strafkommando?
George Kaldore: Strafkommando, weil wir sind gegangen barfuß – wir haben müssen ausziehen die Schuhe .....
David Boder: Sie mussten die Schuhe ..... (beide sprechen) ...
George Kaldore: Wir mussten ausziehen die Schuhe bevor wir sind heraus gegangen und mussten barfuß gehen den ganzen Weg durch die Strecke, wo Steine sind gelegen. Und einmal gemusst laufen, einmal langsam gehen und bei jedem Herausgang haben wir gemusst heraus führen der, das Essen für uns für Mittag. Das heißt ein fünfzig (50) Liter Fass haben zwei (2) Menschen getragen auf dem Weg, barfuß – das heiße Essen. Und nach zwei, drei hundert (2, 300) Menschen wieder zwei (2) Menschen. Aber die, die getragen haben das Fass barfuß, haben gemusst so laufen, wie die anderen Menschen. Sie haben nicht gedarft bleiben, da bleiben hinter der Gruppe .... nicht da bleiben ..... nicht .....
David Boder: Zurück bleiben.
George Kaldore: .... zurück bleiben hinter der Gruppe. Und wir sind heraus gegangen und dort gearbeitet. Es waren dort die SS Menschen und die Wehrmacht. Die Wehrmacht – nicht SS – die SS war nur Einer, ein Oberstabsführer und der Rest – es war die Wehrmacht. Die Wehrmacht waren alte Menschen; wir haben mit ihnen gesprochen und sie haben mit uns gesprochen. Es waren solche alte Menschen, was waren ganz gut zu uns und einmal .... einmal haben sie gegeben ein Stückchen Brot. Sie selbst haben nicht gehabt Essen – die Wehrmacht. Aber wenn gekommen ist der SS Oberstabsführer, hat er bald gesagt, die, die Wehrmacht-Menschen : ‚Jetzt arbeitet, es kommt die SS’ und, hm, stark gearbeitet, sehr stark. Von .... wir sind aufgestanden um vier (4) Uhr in der Früh, um halb .... jeder hat sich gemusst waschen in dem Waschraum. Und es ist gewesen dann Frühstück. Zum Frühstück haben wir bekommen drei hundert (300) Gramm Brot mit zwanzig (20) Gramm, hm, Margarine. Nicht - die synthetische Margarine, das hat nicht Fett gehabt, die deutsche Margarine. Und das war das ganze Brot für uns, das haben wir ....
David Boder: Aus was war die synthetische Margarine gemacht?
George Kaldore: Das wir wissen es nicht von was man das gemacht hat, das hat man synthetisch gemacht von etwas, aber es war nicht fetthaltend. Es hat ganz gut gerochen und gut geschmeckt hat es, aber es hat nicht gehabt keine Kräfte .... keinen Kalorien hat es nicht gehabt. Dann haben wir bekommen bitteren schwarzen Kaffee. Das Wasser im Lager – nicht in Auschwitz und Birkenau, nicht in Monovitz, aber in Buna Werke hat nicht gedarft trinken das Wasser, denn es war Typhus, es war typhus’iges Wasser. Man hat Typhus bekommen von dem Wasser und es war auch sehr schlecht das Wasser. Und wir sind dann herausgegangen zu der Arbeit, zuerst sind wir gegangen zum Appell, der Appell war um fünf (5) Uhr), der hat gedauert eine ganze Stunde, das ist sechs (6) Uhr. Um sechs (6) Uhr beim Appell hat man gezählt die Menschen und jeder hat abgegeben die Zahl, wieviel er hat in seinem Kommando. Und wenn es hat nicht gestimmt, hat man gedarft stehen bis hat gestimmt die Zahl.
David Boder: Aber sie haben arbeiten doch müssen?
George Kaldore: Man hat gestehen, bis es hat nicht gestimmt .....
David Boder: ... bis es gestimmt hat (beide sprechen – Rest unverständlich)
George Kaldore: ... hat nicht gestimmt bei dem Herausgehen ....
David Boder: Sagen Sie, bis die Zahl hat gestimmt.
George Kaldore: .... hat gestimmt., ja, ja. Bei dem Herausgehen vor dem Tor ist gestanden ein Arzt. Und wer hat gefühlt sich krank, ist zu dem Arzt gegangen. Und wenn es war richtig krank, hat gedarft – konnte bleiben im Lager. Und wenn die Krankheit war so, 2, 3 Tage oder eine Woche hat man ihn ausgeheilt und er ist wieder gegangen zu der Arbeit. Aber wenn er hat gehabt schon so eine Krankheit, dass man hat nicht gekonnt heilen, hat man ihn geführt mit einem Auto nach Auschwitz und er wurde dort verbrannt.
David Boder: Wieso wissen Sie das?
George Kaldore: Das wissen wir von dort sind gekommen Menschen, die haben getroffen dort mit Solche was ist gekommen von dort. Und schon später haben wir gesprochen mit solche vom Kommando – Leute, Ungarische, die haben gearbeitet in dem Kommando – in dem tot verbrennt Kommando. Dort haben sie gearbeitet drei (3) Monate die Menschen. Und nach drei (3) Monaten hat man sie abgewechselt und weiter geschickt in andere Lager.
David Boder: Nun?
George Kaldore: Wir sind dann heraus gegangen zu der Arbeit und man hat uns wieder bei dem Tor abgezählt und dann gegangen zu der Arbeit bis zwölf (12) Uhr. Um zwölf (12) Uhr sind wir gegangen essen. Das Essen war ein halber ( ½ ) Liter Suppe. Die Suppe war ein halber ( ½ ) Liter Wasser, gar nichts drinnen, ich weiß nicht , was das war. Grüne Blätter was man, was ist herein gekocht in das warme Wasser, das haben wir bekommen. Und wir haben das gegessen und von zwölf (12) Uhr bis ein (1) Uhr haben wir gehabt dort frei und wir haben uns niedergelegt in dem Gras und ein bisschen geschlafen. Um ein (1) Uhr sind wir gegangen zurück zu der Arbeit und haben gearbeitet bis um fünf (5) Uhr. Dass heißt im Juni um fünf (5) Uhr. Später, wenn die Zeit ist schon da, wenn das Wetter ist schon dunkel gewesen, haben wir nicht so ..... so spät gearbeitet. Wir haben gearbeitet nur bis es war ganz hell das Wetter. Nach der Verdunkelung sind wir gegangen herein in .... mit die Kommandos in das Lager. Wir sind gegangen auf den Appell Platz und auf dem Appell Platz hat man uns wieder abgezählt. Schon bei dem Hereingehen hat man uns abgezählt, aber bei dem Appell Platz wieder abgezählt. Und nach dem Abzählen sind wir gegangen uns waschen. Jeder hat sich gemusst waschen und nach dem Waschen haben wir bekommen das Abendessen. Das Abendessen ist gewesen drei Viertel ( ¾ ) Liter Suppe, die drei Viertel ( ¾ ) Liter Suppe war schon ein bisschen, hm, gedachte Suppe, hat das geheißen, es ist nicht so schütter gewesen, sondern schon ein bisserl Kartoffel herein gekocht oder Rüben; diese Rüben was hat man früher gegeben in Ungarn für die Tier, die Tiere – diese roten Rüben und die weißen Rüben. Und nach dem Essen, nach dem Essen jede Woche einmal hat man gemusst sich ganz abrasieren. Die Haare waren ganz abgeschnitten mit einer Nuller Maschine und jede Woche einmal rasieren. Hm, mit zwei (2) Messer hat man rasiert zwei hundert (200), drei hundert (300) Menschen ohne zu schärfen das Messer, es war, es war eine „Operation“ jedes Rasieren. Und die Menschen haben bekommen sogenannte Bartflechte, Infektion auf dem Gesicht, hm ..... was ..... mit dieser Infektion haben sie hässlich ausgeschaut. Und mit dieser Infektion haben sie dich nicht rasiert, so dass Menschen sind herum gegangen mit ein (1) monatigem alten Bart, mit zwei (2), mit sechs (6), mit zwei (2) monatigem Bart haben sie sehr, sehr hässlich ausgeschaut. Und nachdem haben wir schon gekonnt niederlegen und schlafen. Es war sehr bitter dort. Es waren zweistöckige Betten, jeder hat gehabt zwei Decken auf die Betten und gar nicht anderes. In jedem Bett haben geschlafen zwei (2) Menschen, Einer bei dem Fuß der Kopf, der Andere auf der anderen Seite. Die Betten sind ungefähr gewesen so, hm, fünfzig (50) Zentimeter, so sechzig (60) Zentimeter breit – die Betten. Die Betten sind gewesen voll mit Wanzen und voll mit Tiere – mit Floh und mit Wanzen.
David Boder: Läuse?
George Kaldore: Läuse sind nicht gewesen in dem Lager. Jede Woche vier (4) Mal ist gewesen Läuse Kontrolle. Jeder hat gemusst tragen sein Hemd zu dem Doktor, in jedem Block ist gewesen ein Doktor und Block Ältester, welche haben gesehen ..... durchgesehen die Hemden, Unterhosen – wir sind ganz nackert hin gegangen zu der Kontrolle und wer hat Läuse gehabt, hat bekommen sehr, sehr große Schläge und schon genommen alle Sachen zur Desinfektion, mit den Betten zusammen. Alles wird desinfiziert. Ich war ein ganzes Jahr im Lager, aber ich hab nie gehabt Läuse.
David Boder: Haben Sie Ihre Sachen gewaschen, ihre Hemden?
George Kaldore: Wir haben, hm, jede Woche haben wir gewaschen einmal die Hemden. Hemden haben wir nicht gehabt, weil die ... wir haben unsere Hemden verkauft, hm, ..... draußen im Kommando für die polnischen Arbeiter. Sie haben gegeben für ein Hemd zwei (2), drei (3) Kilo Brot, so dass wir nicht gehabt haben keine Hemden. Nur wir haben gehabt die Kleider was wir haben gehabt.
David Boder: Hat man nicht gefragt, wo ist das Hemd?
George Kaldore: Bei dem Hereingehen man hat gesagt, jede zweite (2.) Woche und später schon jeden Monat wir müssen rein geben die alte Wäsche und damals haben wir genommen einen Fetzen und haben gesagt, es ist zerrissen geworden das Hemd. Wir haben das herein gegeben, das ist unser Hemd und wir haben bekommen andere Hemden, aber diese Hemden waren auch zerrissen .....
David Boder: Sie sagen die Polnischen. Was waren das für Polnische?
George Kaldore: Das waren Pollacken, das waren nicht keine Juden. Das waren Pollacken, die haben gearbeitet dort. Die haben die Arbeit geführt . Und, hm, wir haben gewaschen unsere Wäsche jede Woche einmal, zweimal, so wie es war schmutzig die Wäsche. Wir haben gehabt ein kleines Stückerl Seife, jede Woche haben wir bekommen. Und die Menschen haben schon gesehen dort im Lager etwas ... ein Funktion zu bekommen. Weil jeder, der eine Funktion gehabt hat im Lager, der hat schon etwas mehr Essen bekommen. Ich selbst hab gearbeitet für den Block Ältesten. Ich hab gewaschen für den Block Ältesten dort die Wäsche, ich habe gestopft für ihn die Strümpfe.
David Boder: Oh ja, was war Ihr Fach, was haben Sie gelernt?
George Kaldore: Ich war ... ich hab Textil ... habe ich gelernt. Ich habe gelernt Strümpfe zu machen, aber neue Strümpfe zu machen und Trikotagen und solche Sachen. Aber ich ... ich war schon zu gewöhnt dazu, dass ich arbeiten muss. Und ich hab dort gewaschen die Hemden für den Block Ältesten und gestopft die Strümpfe und auch hier hab ich bekommen jeden Tag „Nachschlagessen“, das hat geheißen noch einmal einen drei Viertel ( ¾ ) Liter Suppe, so dass ....
David Boder: Was ist mit Brot?
George Kaldore: Brot habe ich nicht ..... da war nicht mehr - 300 Gramm Brot das war das Ganze; was wir haben in der Früh bald aufgegessen. Und wir haben so unser Leben gehabt jeden Tag so zwei Monate, das heißt bis August. Im August hat man ausgewählt, man hat gefragt ‚Wer hat ein Fach?’. Den hat man eingeteilt in Fachkommandos. Das heißt Fachkommando, solche Kommandos waren Schlosser oder Ingenieure oder Buchhalter oder Tischler, Fenstermacher, Maler und die haben gearbeitet in dem Gewerbe in der Fabrik. In der Fabrik haben gearbeitet so ungefähr hundert tausend (100000) Menschen. Es war dort ein riesig großes Lager. Nicht nur Häftlinge – Juden – waren dort. Es waren dort polnische Lager, polnische, christliche Erziehungslager. Es war dort ein deutsche, reichsdeutsches Lager, solche welche, die waren bestraft, Kommunisten oder welche haben teilgenommen in der spanischen Revolution Deutsche. Es waren dort französischer Arbeitsdienst. Es waren dort englische, amerikanische Soldaten – Kriegsgefangene, die bei uns im Lager haben sie gewohnt. Und es waren dort noch Pollacken, freie Menschen, Reichsdeutsche, freie Menschen und wir Juden, Ukrainer und Menschen von der ganzen Welt, Leute von Flandern, Belgien, jede, jede Nation haben wir hier ......
David Boder: Das war wo?
George Kaldore: Das war in den Buna Werken. Und ich war damals eingeteilt worden in einem Schlosser Kommando, in einem Techniker Kommando. Ich bin herein gegangen in dem Kraftwerk arbeiten mit einem Kommando, nicht als Schlosser, sondern als Elektrotechniker. Ich hab gearbeitet dort bei der AEG, Allgemeine Elektrische Gesellschaft, was hat gegeben für das ganze Werk das Elektro. Und wir haben dort gemacht die Fassungen, wir haben dort gearbeitet bei der Hochspannung, bei den Kabeln. Dort habe ich es ganz gut gehabt. Wir haben von Zeichnungen gemacht solche Sachen was war sehr schöne Arbeit. Und dort habe ich zusammen gearbeitet mit Pollacken, christliche Pollacken, welche haben mir gegeben hartes Brot oder etwas Essen. Sie haben selbst nicht viel gehabt, aber sie haben gegeben. Und ich bin herein gegangen jeden Tag in die Büro und ich hab von dem Schmutzkasten herausgenommen, hm, dort weg geworfene Pommidoren; weil ich hab immer gesagt, ich darf essen, was ich sehe, weil, wenn ich esse, dann habe ich die Stärke weiter zu arbeiten. Und der Capo hat das nicht mit gutem Willen gesehen, dass ich hab dort bekommen etwas zu essen und er hat mich gegeben in seinem Kommando in eine schwere Arbeit. Ich hab gearbeitet später fünf Stock unter der Erde. Es war so, dass das ganze, hm, das ganze, der Bau, das ganze Werk gebaut fünf (5) Stock unter der Erde.
David Boder: Die Buna Werke?
George Kaldore: Die Buna Werke, ja. Und ich habe dort Kabel gelegt und es war sehr, sehr kalt. Wir sind schon damals rein gegangen in September Und die Nerven sind damals schon gewesen ganz apathisch, wir haben schon gar nichts gedacht, wir haben nichts gewusst. Einmal, einmal haben wir getroffen und deutsche Zeitungen gelesen, aber das war alles deutsche Tendenz. Wir haben gesehen schreckliche Sachen in dem Lager. Wir sind herein gekommen bei dem Appell haben wir gesehen – aufhängen Menschen, auf einmal drei (3) Menschen. Auf einmal zwei (2) Menschen.
David Boder: Wofür?
George Kaldore: Es ist gewesen, drei (3)Menschen hat man aufgehängt, weil sie haben bei Fliegeralarm, drei (3) Juden haben bei Fliegeralarm Brot gestohlen vom Magazin, ein bisschen Bot – nicht viel und man hat sie aufgehangen.
David Boder: Gleich am Appell Platz?
George Kaldore: Auf dem Appell Platz, aber wie das war .... das war so, wie ich es auch gelesen habe in der lateinischen Geschichte, im Zirkus. Der Cäsar hat das gesehen wie man ... wie die Menschen sind dort kaputt gegangen. So haben wir das gesehen. Wir sind herein gekommen auf den Appell Platz, da ist gestanden schon, der .... wie heißt das? Gargul .....
David Boder: Der Galgen.
George Kaldore: Der Galgen ist gestanden, drei nebeneinander gestanden, drei Reflektoren.
David Boder: Wann war das, am Abend?
George Kaldore: Am Abend, ja, um sechs (6) Uhr ist es gewesen. Es war schon September und es ist schon gewesen so dunkel. Und wir sind dort gestanden und ich habe nie im Leben gesehen einen Mensch kaputt gehen. Nicht aufhängen, nicht abschießen und ich habe gefragt: ‚Was wird da, was wird da los/’ ‚Ah, man wird Juden aufhängen’, hab ich gehört. Wir sind dort gestanden schon eine Stunde und man bringt die drei (3) Juden. Die drei (3) Juden – die Hände sind mit einer Geißel zusammen gebunden, der SS bringt sie bei den Gorgel, die SS in der Reihe ...
David Boder: Bei den Galgen?
George Kaldore: Bei den Galgen, ja, ja. Ich kann das nicht so gut ausdrücken. Dort sind gestanden die SS Menschen mit die Büchsen und man hat sie herauf gestellt auf den Gagel ...
David Boder: Auf den Galgen.
George Kaldore: Galgen, ja, Galgen und, hm, die SS ist gestanden und hat so gesagt auf deutsch, im Befehl von Himmler – hat er gesagt, auf Befehl von Himmler wird man da aufhängen drei (3) Juden, weil sie haben beim Fliegeralarm gestohlen Brot.. ‚Juden, ihr sollt wissen, bei Fliegeralarm darf man nicht stehlen. Und überhaupt man darf nicht stehlen, ihr bekommt da genug zu essen, ihr sollt das essen, was ihr da bekommt.’
George Kaldore: Und die Juden sind dort gestanden und haben geschrien: ‚Kameraden, Kameraden, wir sind die Letzten. Rauf mit die Köpfe. Die Fa........, die Faschisten werden alle sterben. Es kommt der Russe, der Russe wird uns befreien.’ Und inzwischen sind hin gegangen die SS und haben mit die Füße ge......, gestoßen und geschlagen noch bei dem Galgen. Und man hat gerufen von den Kommandos drei Juden, von deine Brüder. Wenn der ist gewesen ein Ungarischer, hat man gerufen drei ungarische Menschen. Und er ist gestanden (unverständlich) und hat gewartet am Galgen so und das ist gewesen ein Pedal ... man ist so mit die Füße rauf getreten auf das Pedal. Da erst ... hat man herauf gelegt auf den Hals die Schnur und es ist herunter gefallen das, hm, ...... das, hm ..... wie heißt das, das Plattform. Sie sind gestanden oben auf einer, ..... auf einer Plattform, die ist, hm, noch runter gefallen und die Juden sind gehangen und wir haben das gesehen. Nach zehn (10) Minuten hat sich noch gewollt heraus nehmen den Hals von dem .... von dem Band. Der Andere ist gleich kaputt gegangen. Und wir haben gemusst dort stehen bis sie sind ganz grau geworden und bis sie sind dort ganz tot gegangen.
David Boder: Was heißt grau geworden?
George Kaldore: Das Gesicht ist grau geworden.
David Boder: Sie haben das Gesicht offen gelassen?
George Kaldore: Ja. Und nachdem jeder ... alle Kommandos haben gemusst vor gehen vor dem Galgen und alle haben gedurft hin schauen. Wer nicht hat hin geschaut, hat gleich bekommen große Ohrfeigen von der SS.
David Boder: (unverständlich – beide sprechen) ... nicht das Gesicht verdeckt?
George Kaldore: Nein, nein, sie haben nicht das Gesicht bedeckt. Und nachdem jeder hat noch gesehen, ist gekommen einer vom Spital, ein Capo und der hat genommen ein Messer und hat herunter geschnitten. Er ist herunter gefallen der Tote und hat schon genommen den Bleistift, hat gespuckt auf den Bauch und hat drauf geschrieben mit dem Tintenbleistift seine Nummer und hat auf die Füße geschrieben seine Nummer. Und man hat ihn schon geführt herein in dem K B, das heißt in den Krankenbau. Von dort hat man genommen - jeden Tag sind gekommen die Autos und haben sie geführt nach Auschwitz zum Verbrennen.
David Boder: Ein Moment, Sie haben eine tattoo number, was ist die Nummer?
George Kaldore: Meine Nummer ist A14187 (A vierzehn tausend ein hundert sieben und achtzig)
David Boder: Und wo hat man Sie tätowiert?
George Kaldore: Man hat mich tätowiert in Birkenau.
David Boder: Hm, nun?
George Kaldore: Und wir sind dort, wir haben das alles durchgeschaut ... durch gesehen. Aber das war nicht nur einmal, das haben wir sehr oft gesehen.
David Boder: Die haben oft Mensch aufgehängt?
George Kaldore: Sehr oft hat man Menschen aufgehängt.
David Boder: Wofür?
George Kaldore: Für Plünderung, für ... für sie haben gewollt weglaufen von dem Lager – nicht vom Lager, von dem Werk. Sie haben sich herein gegraben in der Erde und, hm, meistens die polnischen Juden, die haben gekonnt sprechen die polnische Sprache. Da ist gewesen mit mir zusammen ein polnischer Arzt, der hat gewohnt von dem Lager drei (3) Kilometer.
David Boder: Ein Jude?
George Kaldore: Ein Jude. Und wenn er ist gegangen herauf auf das Dach hat er gesehen sein eigenes Haus. Und solche Menschen haben gekonnte .... haben gehabt vielleicht die Möglichkeit raus zu gehen. Aber man hat sie immer erwischt und es war Todesstrafe.
David Boder: Hat man den Arzt auch aufgehängt?
George Kaldore: Ja. Man hat ihn auch aufgehängt. Wir haben gesehen ihn aufhängen. Nach dem Aufhängen sind wir gegangen essen und jeder eigenen hat gegessen. Es waren alle schon so apathisch, jeder hat gegessen und nicht gesprochen schon weiter über das was er gesehen hat.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 97 [incorrect — this is the end of Spool 98] of George Kaldore and we are going over to Spool 98. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording, August 31st, 1946, Tardate, Milano — Tradate, Milano.
David Boder: This is Spool 99, a continuation of Spool 97, 98. August 31st, 1946 at Tradate near Como and Milan. The interviewee is George Kaldore. The third spool of his interview.
George Kaldore: Ja, ich hab jetzt gesagt, wir sind schon gewesen, das, hm, wir sind ganz apathisch gewesen und wir sind ganz apathisch gewesen und die Menschen sind herein gegangen nach dem Aufhängen, wie sie gesehen haben aufhängen ihre eigenen Kameraden, sind herein gegangen dort und haben gegessen das Nachtmahl, das sie haben bekommen und haben weiter gemacht ihr Häftlingsleben. So, wir haben die schwere Arbeit weiter gemacht bis, hm, ..... ich hab weiter gemacht bis Dezember. Im Dezember war es schrecklich kalt. Es hat geregnet und wir sind durch und durch nass geworden. Mit unserem einen, einzigen Kleid, das wir gehabt haben, das von Leinwand gemacht ist, das blau weiß gestreifte Kleid ...... im Dezember sind wir gestanden um fünf (5) Uhr in der Früh auf dem Appell Platz und wir sind raus gegangen zu der Arbeit. Und bei der Arbeit ich war unter der Erde fünf (5) Stock und hab gearbeitet dort in der größten Kälte.
David Boder: Was haben Sie dort gemacht?
George Kaldore: Ich habe dort Kabel gelegt, die Kabel aufgehängt – die Hochkabel. Das waren sehr große Kabel von großem Gewicht und aufhängen auf der, auf der Mauer. Und, hm, ich hab schon gespürt, ich habe Fieber, aber ich wollte nicht herein gehen in K B. K B hat geheißen das Spital.
David Boder: Was heißt das?
George Kaldore: Krankenbau. Ich habe nicht gewollt herein gehen, weil ich habe gehört, wer geht herein, der, hm, ... wird nicht ausgeheilt. Und ich war schon so krank, dass ich nicht hab gekonnt weiter arbeiten. Ich hab bekommen eine Blutauf .........eine Blutvergiftung auf dem Fuß, ich hab schon gekonnt nicht aufnehmen meine Schuhe. Ich bin herein gegangen in der Ambulanz und der Arzt hat gemessen mein Fieber. Ich hab gehabt vierzig (40) Grad Fieber and der Arzt hat gesagt morgen in der Früh soll ich herein gehen ins Spital. Es ist gewesen so, dass wer ..... wen der Arzt aufgeschrieben hat, dass er darf rein gehen ins Spital, der hat gegeben die Liste dem Block Ältesten. Der Block Älteste hat in der Früh rein gebracht die Menschen. Ich war nicht auf der Liste. Ich habe geweint und ich bin rein gegangen ins Spital und habe gesagt dem Professor ... dem, dem Arzt, dass, hm, er soll mich aufnehmen. Ich kann schon keine Schuhe aufnehmen mehr. Ich bin gegangen barfuss mit vierzig (40) Grad Fieber im Dezember. Es war .... (beide sprechen – unverständlich)
David Boder: Warum haben Sie keine Schuhe nicht getragen?
George Kaldore: Weil meine Füße waren so geschwollen, dass der Schuh ist schon nicht mehr herauf gekommen auf meinen Fuß. Es war schon der zwanzigste (20.) Dezember, man hat mich aufgenommen ins Spital. Das ist nicht so leicht gegangen. Man hat mich untersucht, dann ist gekommen der SS Oberarzt und der SS Oberarzt hat aufgenommen. Dann hat man uns weg genommen alle Kleider, was wir gehabt haben, das heißt die Hosen, die Schuhe .... und wir sind geblieben ganz nackert. So dann sind wir herein gegangen in den Infektionsraum und da hat man uns desinfiziert und so herein geführt in die Abteilung, wo die Krankheit gehört hat.
David Boder: Wie hat man sie desinfiziert?
George Kaldore: Hm, es waren dort Duschen und mit Petroleum hat man uns abgeschmiert ganz und die Haare hat man wieder abgeschnitten und ganz abrasiert. So und dann wird herein gegangen. Es war ..... es hat dort gestunken. In einem kleinen Saal sind gewesen drei hundert (300) Menschen, alle mit eitrigen Krankheiten. Und alle .... der Eine ist schon geschnitten geworden, der Andere war noch krank und schon tot und solche Menschen, was nicht viel gefehlt hat zu dem Tod. Ich bin dort herein gegangen und zwei Menschen in einem Bett und so ganz nackert herunter gelegt. Dort war Heizung von den Werken, es ist gekommen der Dampf von dem Werk herein, so war dort ein bisschen eingeheizt. Wir haben dort auch nur zwei (2) Decken gehabt. Der andere Kamerad, was ist mit mir zusammen gelegen in dem Bett, hat gehabt .... ist geflossen Eiter von seiner Hand. Und ich bin mit ihm in einem Bett gelegen. Erstens hat man mir gegeben Umschläge auf die Füße zwei Tage, am dritten (3.) Tag hat man mich operiert.. Am Weihnachtstag war das, am fünf und zwanzigsten (25.) .....
David Boder: Da waren zwei (2) Kranke in einem Bett?
George Kaldore: In einem Bett zwei (2) Kranke.
David Boder: Woran hat man Sie operiert?
George Kaldore: Man hat mich operiert die Füße – aufgeschnitten. Es war so, man hat mich aufgeschrieben zu der Operation. Jeden Früh hat man aufgeschrieben zwanzig (20), dreißig (30) Menschen zur Operation. Die zwanzig Mensch gekommen ein Arzt – sagen: ‚Die Menschen werden heute operiert, sie sollen gehen und erledigen ihre Sachen – ihre Toilettensachen’. Und so nackert wie wir sind gewesen dort, sind wir gegangen zu der Operation und hat gewartet bis die Reihe zu uns kommt. Der Operationssaal ist gewesen dort in dem Saal, nur ein Vorhang ist gewesen, was hat separiert von dem anderen Saal. Und herein gegangen dort, es war ein ungarischer Arzt von Kosice, ein Oberarzt. Und ich habe ihn gebeten, er soll mich so operieren, dass ich schlafe. Und ich hab eine Narkose bekommen und er hat mich operiert und nach der Operation habe ich gemusst auf einem Fuß, so nackert zurück zu gehen. Man hat mich nicht herein getragen.
David Boder: Ja, nachdem Sie aus der Narkose raus gekommen?
George Kaldore: Ja, die Narkose war nur bis zur Operation. Nur zwei (2), drei (3) Minuten bis die Operation gehalten hat.
David Boder: Was hat er denn gemacht?
George Kaldore: Er hat aufgeschnitten die Füße – unten die Füße aufgeschnitten und zugebunden, so dass ich bin so operiert bin reingegangen in mein Bett.
David Boder: Was machen Ihre Füße jetzt?
George Kaldore: Die Füße sind geheilt geworden, die sind schon ganz gut.
David Boder: Hat er an beiden Füßen operiert?
George Kaldore: Nur an einem Fuß.
David Boder: Waren beide geschwollen?
George Kaldore: Nur ein Fuß war geschwollen.
David Boder: Nun.
George Kaldore: Und das war am Weihnachtstag. Das Essen nachdem ..... das Essen in dem Spital war auch nicht besser. Wir haben bekommen drei hundert (300) Gramm Essen, ...... Brot in der Früh und einen halben ( ½ ) Liter Suppe am Mittag und drei Viertel ( ¾ ) Liter Suppe am Abend. Und wir sind den ganzen Tag gelegen und haben gar nichts gemacht.
David Boder: Was war das für eine Suppe?
George Kaldore: Die Mittagssuppe war die Buna Suppe, das war dieses .... warme Wasser mit grünen Blättern. Am Abend haben wir bekommen, die, die Suppe mit ein bisschen Kartoffel oder Rüben oder Kraut in der Suppe. Und wir haben geglaubt ....
David Boder: Und wo von haben Sie gegessen?
George Kaldore: Das hat man gegessen , damals.... das hat man gegessen von, von einer Schale. Wir haben getrunken die Suppe, wir haben nichts gehabt keinen Löffel zum essen, nicht ein Messer das Bot zu schneiden.
David Boder: Ja.
George Kaldore: Nur getrunken von der Schale. Und das war am Weihnachtstag und wir haben geglaubt an Weihnachten, Weihnachten werden wir bekommen eine Plus Ration für Weihnachten, das große Fest für die Christen, aber wir haben nichts bekommen – keine Plus Rationen. Ich bin dort gelegen bis am dritten (3.) Jänner. Am ersten (1.) Jänner habe ich gehab meinen Geburtstag. Ich bin zu gegangen zu dem Block Ältesten und ich hab gesagt ihm: ‚Herr Block Ältester, ich hab heute meinen Geburtstag. Ich möchte Ihnen bitten, eben Sie mir heute noch eine, eine Portion Essen.’ Und er hat mir gegeben noch eine Portion. Das haben gesehen die anderen Menschen und sie haben gesagt: ‚Ich hab auch Geburtstag.’ Und am nächsten Tag sind sie auch zu ihm gegangen. Und er hat ja die Kartotheken gehabt von uns. Und er hat gesagt: ‚Gut, Du bekommst Dein Essen, aber wenn das nicht Dein Geburtstag heute, dann wirst Du tot geschlagen.’ Und ich hab gesehen wie eine Deutsche zu schlagen dort einen Kranken.
David Boder: Dort in dem Spital?
George Kaldore: In dem Hospital geschlagen, weil er da zugegangen und gesagt hat, er hat einen Geburtstag und er wollte bekommen noch einen Liter zu essen. Und nachdem ich bin ein bisschen besser geworden, aber ich habe noch nicht gekonnt aufstehen auf dem anderen Fuß. Man hat mich rüber getragen in den anderen Saal, wo sind schon gewesen die operierten Kranken, die schon ein bisschen besser gefühlt sich und wir sind dort geblieben bis am zehnten (10.) Jänner. Man hat mich schon gewollt heraus führen von dort, weil es hat schon geheilt meine Wunde, aber ich selbst habe mir ..... habe mir aufgekratzt die Wunde bevor der Visite, dass man soll nicht sehen, dass es heilt die Wunde. Und man hat mich gemessen das Fieber und da habe ich auch das Fieber aufgewärmt das, hm ..... Thermometer ......
David Boder: Wie haben Sie das getan?
George Kaldore: Das hab ich mit der Decke, hm, .... hab ich .....
David Boder: Gerieben.
George Kaldore: .... hab ich gerieben ja, dass das Thermometer soll herauf gehen, so dass ich soll Fieber haben und ....
David Boder: Wo haben Sie das Thermometer gehabt, in dem Mund oder in ...
George Kaldore: Nein, unter dem Arm. Und wenn ist gekommen der Arzt, ... gesehen, er hat gesehen, dass ich auch Fieber habe, dann hat er mich nicht heraus geschickt. Ich hab gesehen, wenn ich geh heraus vom Spital mit den Leinen Anzüge, werde ich .... werde ich erfrieren dort draußen und nachdem, wir haben schon gehört manchmal, man hat schon gesprochen, dass die Russen kommen ...
David Boder: Wer hat das gesagt?
George Kaldore: Die Block Ältesten. Sie haben schon gepackt dort Sachen. Die Block Ältesten und die Ärzte, die haben schon genäht dort von Kotzen, von Decken hat man schon genäht die Rucksäcke. Für das Spital – man hat schon ausgegeben für das Spital Sachen – so Arznei und Koffer, damit man einpacken kann das ganze Spital. Und so sind wir dort geblieben im Spital und wir haben gehört die Russen kommen. Und an einem Tag ist das Lager schon nicht heraus gegangen, das war am fünf zehnten (15.) Januar. Das Lager ist nicht heraus gegangen und man hat gesagt darum, weil es ist zehn (10) Grad kalt oder fünfzehn (15) Grad kalt und wegen der Kälte zwingt man nicht das Lager zu arbeiten. Aber wir haben schon gewusst, dass die Russen kommen und man wird schon evakuieren das Lager. Und eine Nacht um acht (8) Uhr hat man gestellt alle Menschen auf den Appell Platz und man hat ausgeteilt sechs hundert (600) Gramm Brot und vier (4) Deka Margarine – das ist vierzig (40) Gramm Margarine und zwanzig (20) Gramm, hm, hm, solche ..... Leberwurst und man hat gesagt, dass das Lager wird weiter gehen. Im Spital hat man die Kranken, was haben nicht gekonnt haben gehen, hat man gelassen dort. Das Lager ist weg gegangen an dem Abend um zwölf (12) Uhr und wir sind nur geblieben – die paar hundert, es kann sein vier hundert (400) Menschen von dem ganzen Lager in dem Spital.
David Boder: Wieso vier hundert (400) Menschen? Waren so viele krank und in dem Spital?
George Kaldore: Vier hundert (400) Menschen waren in dem Hospital von zehn tausend (10000). Das Häftlingslager dort in den Buna Werken hat ja gezählt zehn tausend (10000) Menschen. Und von den zehn tausend (10000) Menschen waren vier hundert (400) Menschen, welche haben nicht gekonnt weiter zu gehen.
David Boder: Nun?
George Kaldore: Ich war damals schon so weit gesund. Und wir sind dort geblieben – ohne Kleider, ohne gar nichts – nur so nackert.
David Boder: Und die Ärzte?
George Kaldore: Die Ärzte sind auch weg gegangen. Nur geblieben im Spital sind die Kranken. Und zwischen den Kranken sind geblieben kranke Ärzte. Und alles weg genommen, alles mit sich genommen. Die Arzneien, die Operationssachen, sie haben alles, alles mit genommen.
David Boder: Und die .... und die Essen?
George Kaldore: Essen haben wir auch bekommen die Ration, wie die, die weggegangen sind – nicht mehr. Und man hat uns gesagt, wir sollen das einteilen, weil das ist das letzte Essen, was sie uns geben.
David Boder: Haben sie auch gesagt, dass sie sie lassen zu den Russen?
George Kaldore: Nein, sie haben gesagt, wir sollen bleiben und es wird kommen ein SS Kommando, das wir uns schon versorgen. Sie haben gewusst, dass versorgen heißt, man wird uns kaputt machen. Am anderen Tag in der Früh bin ich heraus gegangen, ich hab mich barfuss und mit einer Decke habe ich mich zugedeckt und bin heraus gegangen in den Block zu suchen Kleider. Ich hab gefunden dort weggeworfene, alte Hosen und weggeworfene, hölzerne Schuhe.
David Boder: Wer hat das weg geworfen?
George Kaldore: Die Menschen was haben .... sind weg gegangen. Sie konnten nicht mitnehmen das mit sich, nur einen Anzug. Und ich hab mich angezogen und ich hab mich getraut weiter zu gehen. Ich habe gewusst ,mein Leben ist schon gar nichts und wir werden kaputt sein oder kaputt sein wegzugehen’. Und so ist es gekommen, dass ich bin ... ich hab mich angezogen und angezogen bin ich herein gegangen in das Bekleidungsmagazin.
David Boder: Da war keine SS? Keine sind geblieben?
George Kaldore: Ja, es sind geblieben zehn (10) SS dort in dem ganzen Lager.
David Boder: Ja.
George Kaldore: Die sind nicht einmal herein gekommen zu uns. Und nachdem bin ich herein gegangen sehen, was in der Küche ist. Wir haben immer gesehen, vielleicht kann man eine, eine Rübe noch dort finden oder etwas. Und man hat alles was die Juden dort gefunden haben ins Spital – welche schon ein bisschen gehen konnten – haben sich zusammen gesammelt auf einem Platz alle Sachen und haben sich angezogen, wer konnte sich anziehen und unter die Betten weg gesteckt die Sachen. Ich habe gefunden dann dort Zivilsachen. Ich hab mich, hm, angezogen zivil und unter der Zivil habe ich gehabt noch den gestreiften Anzug. Und ich bin herein gegangen in eine Werkstatt und habe dort gefunden Zangen. Und wir haben ......
David Boder: Hat man gearbeitet in der Werkstatt?
George Kaldore: Dort ist gewesen von SS ein, eine Werkstatt, wo man hat repariert die Autos von der SS.
David Boder: Hat man dort gearbeitet?
George Kaldore: Ja, man hat dort gearbeitet .... damals schon nicht mehr, aber früher....
David Boder: Vorher, nicht wie Sie sind rein gegangen sind.
George Kaldore: Ja, man hat nicht gearbeitet. Wir haben genommen die Zangen und auch weg gesteckt. Es ist gelegen mit mir in dem Bett ein ungarischer Ingenieur .....Ingenieur. Und wir haben gesagt, wir werden überschneiden die Drahte, weil die Drahte sind ja noch gestanden unter Hochspannung .... Elektro Hochspannung und hm, wir werden das durchschneiden und dort heraus gehen in die Bunker hinein. Wir wollen nicht bleiben in dem Lager. In der Nacht ist gekommen eine sehr große amerikanische, englische Vernichtungsbombadierung. Wir sind gewesen in dem Spital in den hölzernen Baracken und die Bomben sind herunter gefallen ein paar hundert (100) Meter von uns und die ganze Baracke hat gewackelt, gewackelt. Die großen Bomben, die kleinen Bomben und nachdem die Entzündbomben. Und das Lager hat bekommen die letzten Bomben, die sind gefallen auf das Lager. Und das Lager hat bekommen eine Entzündbombe und es ist gewesen Wind und die, die hölzernen Baracken sind gebrannt, gebrannt und es ist schon nicht gewesen Elektrizität in den Drähten und sie Juden sind alle gegangen heraus. Und es ist gekommen die SS und hat geschrieen ‚Keiner soll nicht heraus gehen, wenn er geht, wenn Einer geht heraus, er wird bald tot sein. Jeder soll bleiben.’ Und es ist gekommen die, hm, Feuerwehr von dem Werk heraus und man hat gelöscht das Feuer. Und es ist gewesen ein Wunder .... das Feuer ist gekommen bis zum Spital und das Spital ist nicht abgebrannt. Das ganze Lager ist abgebrannt, nur das Spital nicht. Und dann .....
David Boder: Hat das Spital das rote Kreuz auf dem Dach gehabt?
George Kaldore: Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das rote Kreuz – es hat nicht gehabt ein rotes Kreuz.. Das Spital hat nicht gehabt ein rotes Kreuz. Und wir haben schon unsere Sachen mit meinen Kameraden heraus genommen und in den Bunker herein und ....
David Boder: Was für ein Bunker?
George Kaldore: Die SS sind gewesen früher in dem Bunker drinnen, hm, bei dem Fliegeralarm.
David Boder: Nun?
George Kaldore: Und wir haben unsere Sachen dort herein genommen, wir haben gesagt, wir werden weiter gehen. Und die Nacht ist herein gekommen die SS und hat gesagt, ob wir nicht ein Wasser haben. Wir haben von der, von der Kantine weg gestohlen ... es waren dort in der Kantine, hm, Sodawasser, solche Mineralwasser in Gläser. Und wir haben gegeben der SS zwei (2) Flaschen Mineralwasser und sie sind weg gegangen. Und nachdem haben wir schon keine SS mehr gesehen. Und wir sind geblieben in dem Bunker ....
David Boder: Warum haben Sie Wasser mitgehabt? Was war mit dem Wasser ... (beide sprechen)
George Kaldore: Es war schon kein Wasser, es war zerbombt. Es war schon kein Wasser, es war schon kein Strom, es war schon gar nichts ... gar nichts zu essen, gar nichts.
David Boder: Und die SS war (unverständlich – beide sprechen)
George Kaldore: Nein, die SS ..... die sind schon, die haben schon gar nichts gesprochen. Sie haben nur gefragt, ob wir haben Wasser und sie haben genommen das Wasser und sind schon weiter gegangen. Sie haben gar nichts gesagt für uns. Und wir sehen auf dem Weg, dass es kommen ein deutsche Wagen (unverständlich – beide sprechen) .....
David Boder: Wohin sind die SS gekommen für das Wasser? In das Hospital?
George Kaldore: In das Spital herein und ....
David Boder: Dann sind sie weg gegangen?
George Kaldore: Dann sind sie weg gegangen.
David Boder: Und Sie, wo waren Sie?
George Kaldore: Wir waren im Hospital. Die Sachen, unsere, waren im Bunker drinnen. Und, hm, wir sehen auf der Strasse vor dem Lager, gehen Gruppen von SS Menschen, es geht dort Militär, Panzerwagen, Autos mit großer Schnelle, es gehen dort ... es gehen dort Pollacken, polnische Menschen und diese Reichsdeutschen und Volksdeutsche mit Wagen; und sie fuhren die, die Sachen und .... und sie gehen weiter. Wir sehen, dass es kommt ..... es kommt etwas .... es kommt die Befreiung für uns. Und wir sind weiter gegangen von dem Bunker – herein in das erste Dorf. Wir sind herein gegangen zu einem polnischen Bauern und wir sagen ihm .... wir haben gesagt dem polnischen Bauern er soll uns lassen herein gehen. Er kann ja sehen, die Deutschen laufen ja weg und die Russen kommen. Er hat uns herein genommen in seinem Haus und er hat uns gegeben ein bisschen Essen. Er hat selbst nicht viel gehabt. Und zwei Tage sind wir gewesen da bei dem Bauern versteckt und in der Nacht sind gekommen die Russen. Wie die Russen gekommen sind, sind wir selbst zurück gegangen in das Lager und in dem Lager waren schon die Menschen froh. Aber von die vier hundert (400) Menschen sind geblieben ungefähr zwei hundert (200). Die Anderen sind gestorben vom Hunger, gestorben vom Typhus, der ist dort ausgebrochen worden. Und wir haben gar nicht gehabt schon ausgezogen. Wir haben gehabt einen Bart schon... von, von ungefähr drei, vier (3, 4) Wochen und es ist gewesen dort die Muselmänner, die haben nur Bein und ....nur, hm, nur Fleisch gehabt auf die .... Fleisch, sag ich, ..... gar nichts gehabt auf ...... nur Bein und Bein.
David Boder: Warum haben Sie sie genannt Muselmänner?
George Kaldore: Nein, Muselmänner ist das so, ich glaub, so abgemagert als der Ghandi, er sieht auch so abgemagert aus und diese Menschen haben auch so abgemagert ausgesehen, nur so Beine und Beine, Sie haben keine .....
David Boder: Nur Haut und Knochen.
George Kaldore: Knochen, Knochen, ja. Und die Russen haben fotografiert und die Russen haben gegeben Essen dort. Sie haben gegeben Brot und haben abgeschlachtet eine ganze, hm, hm, .... Kuh und haben das Fleisch gebracht herein und wir haben gekocht .....
David Boder: Von wo haben sie die Kuh gehabt?
George Kaldore: Von den Polen. Sie haben von den Polen weg genommen, die Kuh. Und sie haben uns gegeben Konserven und wir haben dort gegessen. Ich hab ja gewusst, man darf nicht viel essen, aber wir haben ja schon, ..... schon lange Zeit nichts gegessen, nur Rüben, nur Kartoffeln und den Schmutz, den wir gefunden haben. Und wir haben gefragt den russischen Offizier, was sollen wir machen. Und er hat gesagt: „Von wo seid ihr?“ Wir haben gesagt: „Wir sind Ungarische.“ Er hat mich gefragt: „Von wo bist Du?“ „Von Ungarn!“ „Du darfst gehen nach Krakau, in Krakau gehen schon die Züge und du kannst gehen nach Hause.“ Das war am fünf und zwanzigsten (25) Januar neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig (1945). Und wir sind fort gegangen. Wir haben genommen noch zwei (2) Kameraden und mit meinem Kameraden vier (4) zusammen – sind zu Fuß gegangen weiter und, hm, Krakau ist gewesen sechzig Kilometer. Und ich mit meinem Fuß, wo ist noch Eiter gewesen drinnen, wir sind gegangen zu Fuß. Und wir haben immer gebeten von den Russen, dass sie sollen uns geben ein bisschen Essen. Der Eine hat uns gegeben ein Brot, der Andere hat uns gegeben ein Stück Konserven und wir haben gegessen .......
David Boder: .... (beide sprechen – unverständlich) ... haben Sie denn nicht gefahren?
George Kaldore: Nein, fahren haben wir nicht gekonnt. Und wir sind in der Nacht herein gegangen zu einer polnischen Familie, die haben dort gewohnt und wir haben gebeten, dass sie erlauben, dass wir uns niederlegen und wir haben dort geschlafen. Sie haben gegeben ein bisschen warme Suppe für uns und wir sind gegangen. Vor Krakau – zwanzig Kilometer – hm, sind gestanden die russischen Wachen. Sie haben uns genommen zusammen und im Transport geführt nach Krakau. In Krakau sind schon gewesen sehr viele Menschen, hm, so befreite Menschen in einem sogenannten großen Platz, wie heißt das .... wie hat das geheißen ..... eine Kaserne. Und die Russen haben uns gegeben dort Verpflegung, Essen und sie haben uns am zweiten (2.) Tag gefragt ... ,Ihr seid die Juden, Christen, Franzosen, allerlei Nationalitäten’ und sie haben gefragt: ‚Wer will Soldat sein?’ Wer wollte ist da reingegangen in die russische Armee. Ich hab gesehen, dass da es wird nicht gut sein. Es war schon sehr großer Schmutz, es waren schon Läuse dort und ich mit meinen Kameraden sind raus gegangen in die Stadt und gesucht dort einen Roten Kreuz. Wir haben jetzt gefunden dort ein Rotes Kreuz, das internationale Rote Kreuz. Wir sind herein gegangen und ich habe gekonnt französisch und mein Kamerad hat auch gut französisch gesprochen und wir haben mit einer kleinen Lüge gegangen. Wir haben gesagt dem polnischen Arzt, dass er ist ein Arzt und ich bin ein Arzt und wir sind vom Lager gekommen und wir sind abgeschwacht. Und ich hab schon nicht gesagt, hm, ich hab nicht gewollt sagen, dass ich bin ein Jude, weil wenn ich sag, ich bin ein Jude, dann nimmt man mich nicht dort an. Wir sagen .... wir haben gesagt, wir sind Franzosen und wir sind vom Lager gekommen.
David Boder: Warum würden sie die Juden nicht annehmen?
George Kaldore: Es war schon damals Antisemitismus da. Und man hat uns nicht .... man hat uns angenommen und rein geführt und ein schönes, weißes, sauberes Bett gegeben und wir sind dort gewesen zwei (2) Wochen und nach zwei Wochen wir haben gearbeitet – wir haben dort die Kranken verpflegt. Und wir sind heraus gegangen in die Stadt und haben gefragt, wie man kann fahren nach Hause. Wir haben ....
David Boder: Nach Ungarn?
George Kaldore: Ungarn, ja. Wir haben gehört, es gibt gar keine Zug. Man kann nicht so fahren, wie wir uns haben das vorbedacht. So wir sind geblieben in Krakau ein ganzes Monat und ..... in dem Spital wir haben es sehr gut gehabt. Wir haben dort bekommen Geld und wir haben dort bekommen ein bisschen Essen, haben wir es gehabt sehr schön, so dass ich hab aufgenommen zehn (10) Kilo. Damals, wie ich bin hingekommen, acht und vierzig Kilo und ich war damals schon fünf und achtzig (85) Kilo, das ist schon sehr schön. Und dann .....
David Boder: Nun also, wie sind Sie nach Italien gekommen?
George Kaldore: Also von dort bin ich gegangen nach ..... von Krakau habe ich bekommen die Schriften von der russischen (unverständlich) und bin gegangen nach Tarnow, Shestov, Przemysl .....
David Boder: Wie sind Sie gereist, mit dem Zug?
George Kaldore: Ja, mit, hm, mit Wagons sind wir gegangen,
David Boder: Haben Sie nicht gebraucht Billetten?
George Kaldore: Nein, sie haben gar nichts gefragt ... Billetten man hat gar nichts gefragt. Wir sind gegangen an den Wegen und wir haben gebettelt für ein Essen und wir sind gefahren durch .... ich habe gesagt Tarnow, Shestov, Przemysl und ich wollte durchfahren bei der Grenze durch Russland nach Ungarn. Man hat uns nicht durch gelassen und wir sind zurück gefahren nach Tarnow, Shestov, Przemysl. Und wir sind zurück gefahren nach Tarnow und von Tarnow nach Krosno und (Name der Stadt unverständlich) Slowakei nach Ungarn, nach Miskolc. In Miskolc hat man uns wieder desinfiziert. Und dort sind wir ..... habe ich gesucht ein jüdisches Hilfs-Kommittee. Einen ungarische Polizei habe ich gefragt: ‚Wohnt da ein Jud in Miskolc?’ ‚Ja.’ Dort habe ich bekommen die erste Hilde und bin dann gegangen nach Budapest. In Budapest habe ich noch gesehen die Toten auf der Strasse, damals war Budapest befreit von die Deutschen und die Russen waren da gewesen. Es waren sehr schwere Verhältnisse in Budapest. Es war nicht kein Essen und ich habe keine Verwandten gefunden dort. Und ich bin herein gegangen zum American Joint, das hat schon da angefangen zu arbeiten und hab dort eine Arbeit bekommen. Ich hab dort gearbeitet als, hm, als Sekretariat bei American Joint in Budapest. Und von dort, hm, hat man mich geschickt nach Szombathely – in meine Heimatstadt, die befreit worden ist von die Deutschen. Und in Szombathely habe ich weiter gearbeitet bei dem Joint – es ist gewesen dort ein Punkt von der österreichischen Grenze, wo sind rüber gekommen die Menschen von Österreich nach Ungern, die deportierten Menschen. Wir haben gegeben die erste Hilfe und ich, wer durch gelebt hat diese Erlebnisse, hab mit dem besten Herz das gemacht und ohne Geld und .... und gerne gemacht.
David Boder: Was heißt ohne Geld? Hat der Joint nicht bezahlt?
George Kaldore: Von Joint haben wir nicht bekommen Bezahlung, wir haben dort bekommen nur Essen und Wohnung von Joint und Anzüge von Joint und wir haben das gemacht schon ohne Geld. Ich keine nicht gefunden von meine Verwandten, keiner ist nicht geblieben von alle große Familie, was ich hab gehabt. Es ist mir geblieben ein Cousin was ist in Neu Seeland. Keinen hab ich nicht. Dort in Szombathely, meiner Heimatstadt, habe ich mich verheiratet. Und ich hab gesagt bei Joint, dass ich will weiterfahren, ich will nach Palästina fahren. Und von dort von Ungarn bin ich nach Italien.
David Boder: Warum nach Italien?
George Kaldore: Weil, hm, von Italien haben wir gewusst ..... von Italien, hm, gehen die Aliyah nach Palästina.
David Boder: Aliyah?
George Kaldore: Aliyah. Aliyah heißt, hm, heißt abfahren, fort fahren. Das ist ein hebräisches, ein jüdisches Wort.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie sich mit dem Kibbuz verbunden?
George Kaldore: Ich war schon lange Zeit in Ungarn vor dem Krieg – als Kind bin ich schon hier gewesen in einer Organisation Hasomer Hacair Zioni, eine jugendliche Organisation, so dass ich war schon drinnen in dieser Organisation Hasomer Hacair Zioni. Ich bin hergekommen, ich wurde empfangen und ich bin herein gegangen in den Kibbuz.
David Boder: Wo?
George Kaldore: Erst bin ich gewesen in Maestre, von Maestre nach Rom, von Rom hat man mich geschickt nach Bari. Im Bari Transit Camp hat man mich registriert bei der UJNRRA, von dort geschickt nach Santa Maria Campani. Dort ist gewesen ein UNRRA Camp. Dort habe ich gelebt im Kibbuz bis Juli. Im Juli hat man mich heraus gebracht nach Rom und von Rom bin ich gewesen weiter auf der Hakshara. Und von Rom bin ich ... hat man mich geführt her auf diesen Platz.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, sind Sie reingekommen nach Italien legal mit dem Visum, mit dem Pass?
George Kaldore: Nein, ich bin illegal gekommen nach Italien.
David Boder: Wie sind Sie rüber gekommen über die Grenze?
George Kaldore: Wir sind ... ich weiß nicht, ob ich kann davon sprechen.
David Boder: Dann nicht. Aber von Ungarn – ist da eine Grenze nach Italien?
George Kaldore: Nein, es ist nicht eine Grenze. Wir sind von Ungarn da durch Jugoslawien und dann durch Österreich , ich bin gefahren durch Jugoslawien nach Italien.
David Boder: Aber wenn man einmal in Italien ist, dann schickt man Sie nicht raus.
George Kaldore: Nein, von Italien schickt man nicht heraus. In Italien registriert die UNRRA. Jetzt schon nicht die UNRRA, jetzt Joint, aber der Kibbuz, die nehmen alle unsere Registration auf von den Menschen und dadurch legalisiert man die Menschen.
David Boder: Man legalisiert sie.
George Kaldore: Man legalisiert sie.
David Boder: Und wie viel Menschen sind in Ihrem Kibbuz?
George Kaldore: Jetzt sind in meinem Kibbuz ... sind da siebzig (70) Menschen.
David Boder: Ja und Ihre Frau ist mit Ihnen im selben Kibbuz?
George Kaldore: Ja im selben Kibbuz.
David Boder: Haben Sie ein Zimmer für sich und Ihre Frau?
George Kaldore: Nein, wir sind, hm, in einem ..... wir sind sechs und dreißig Leute in so einem Zimmer jetzt ...
David Boder: Männer und Frauen zusammen?
George Kaldore: ..... Männer und Frauen zusammen. Alle verheiratet – so, dass wir liegen in einem Bett, zwei zusammen .... (beide sprechen)
David Boder: ..... zwei (unverständlich)
George Kaldore: ... die Frau zusammen mit, hm, ......
David Boder: ..... mit dem Mann.
George Kaldore: .... mit dem Mann.
David Boder: Und da sind andere Frauen und Männer im selben Zimmer?
George Kaldore: Ja, im selben Zimmer. Zehn (10) Zentimeter weg ist das andere Bett. Das ist so, hm, wie ....
David Boder: Wie kann man so leben?
George Kaldore: Es ist sehr schwer so zu leben, aber wir leben gerne so, weil wir wissen, das es ist vielleicht nicht so lange die Zeit, bis wir werden ein freies Leben haben. Wir werden frei sein in unserem Land, wo wir streben. In Palästina wir werden sein Menschen, wir können arbeiten; wir werden schon nicht essen das Brot was uns UJNRRA und Joint gibt.
David Boder: Aber weiß die UNRRA, dass Sie so leben?
George Kaldore: UNRRA weiß nicht, weil die UNRRA damals kommt und zeigt uns die andere Seite von dem Leben. Und wenn er es weiß, macht er, als ob er nicht wissen davon oder reden. Wenn er will etwas machen, kann er registrieren die anderen Menschen auch.
David Boder: Was heißt „die anderen Menschen“?
George Kaldore: Was noch nicht registriert sind, die was kommen illegal von ..... jetzt .....
David Boder: Ja, aber da zu leben, so zu leben mit Familien ...... wie da, weiß die UNRRA .....
George Kaldore: Davon weiß die UNRRA; ja, ja, ja, ja, weiß die UNRRA. Da ist gewesen bei uns auch Kontrolle, eine medizinische Kontrolle von Joint und die haben es gesehen genau. Und sie haben ausgemessen das Zimmer als Kubikmeter und sie haben gesagt, man kann wohnen so viele in einem Zimmer.
David Boder: Aber ... Frauen und Männer? Sind da Kinder dabei im selben Zimmer?
George Kaldore: Ja, wir sind zusammen in dem Zimmer.
David Boder: Nun und hat niemand verlangt, dass sie bessere Bedingungen zum Leben haben?
George Kaldore: Das ist nicht da bessere Bedingungen. Wir wissen das und wir wollen jetzt nicht bessere Bedingungen. Wir wollen bessere Bedingungen in Erez haben, in unserem Land. Wir werden da nicht lang sein. Wir werden weiter gehen so bald als möglich und wir hoffen auch, dass wir werden .....
David Boder: Sind schon manche Menschen gegangen?
George Kaldore: Ja, es sind .... meine ... sehr, sehr viele Kameraden sind schon weg gegangen. Mein Schwager, was ist mit mir zusammen gewesen, meine besten Kameraden sind schon ....
David Boder: Und haben Sie bekommen die Zertifikate, um zu gehen nach Palästina?
George Kaldore: Sie haben nicht Zertifikate bekommen, sie sind illegal gegangen.
David Boder: Und jetzt, wo die Engländer sie nach Zypern nehmen – in Konzentrationslager?
George Kaldore: Werden wir auch gehen, ist egal ob legal oder illegal. Ja, wir werden gehen illegal, aber wir werden gehen. Und wenn man uns nach Zypern führt, dann werden wir auch gehen, weil wir werden wissen, wenn man uns von Zypern wegführt, wir werden nicht sein (unverständlich – murmelt), es wir nicht lange sein - in Zypern auch nicht.
David Boder: Nun wie kriegt man die Schiffe zu gehen?
George Kaldore: Da wissen wir gar nichts, darüber will ich auch nicht sprechen.
David Boder: Oh ja, ich will auch Sie nicht fragen. (unverständlich – Mikrophon scheint nicht richtig zu funktionieren). Und von wo kommen jetzt die neuen Menschen her?
George Kaldore: Neue Menschen kommen von Polen. In Polen ist der Antisemitismus und sie gehen nach Österreich. Wir lesen ja in den Zeitungen, es wird geschrieben in den jüdischen Zeitungen, dass sie von Polen kommen. Die Tschechoslowakei hat nach Amerika ein Ultimatum gemacht, dass Amerika erlaubt, dass die amerikanische Zone, dass die Juden nach Österreich kommen und von Österreich dann kommen sie her.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 99 taken at Tradate between Milan and Como on August 31st, 1946. This concludes Kaldore, George Kaldore. Illinois Institute of Technology Wire Recording.